bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat alors que le
gouvernement planche actuellement sur
trois ou quatre scénarios de réforme de
la fiscalité du patrimoine
allant de la suppression pure et simple
de l'isf et du bouclier fiscal au
relèvement de la fiscalité des plus
fortunés
la commission des finances du sénat a
organisé une table ronde sur ce thème en
présence de quatre économistes dont
thomas piketty dont l' ouvrage en faveur
d'une révolution fiscale est en tête des
meilleures ventes d'essais actuellement
thomas piketty professeur d'économie à
paris estime qu'il faut revoir tout le
système fiscal français à commencer par
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est donc cette
table ronde que je vous propose de
suivre tout de suite un bonne matinée a
tous bien mes chers collègues de
reprenons nos auditions
et nous accueillons maintenant et quatre
experts quatre économistes
s'il vous plaît la séance est reprise
nous accueillons quatre experts quatre
économistes qui ont bien voulu répondre
à notre invitation la commission des
finances entend prendre part activement
à la réflexion en cours sur la réforme
de la fiscalité du patrimoine
nous avons ouvert une série d'auditions
la semaine passée nous entendions le
directeur de l' ocde recharger des
politiques fiscales dans les différents
états de l' ocde et ce matin nous
accueillons jean hervé lorenzi
professeur à l'université dauphine
président du cercle des économistes
nous accueillons christian saint-etienne
professeur au cnam et membre du conseil
d'analysé économique
nous accueillons thomas piketty
économiste et professeur à l'école
d'économie de paris et david desmare
économiste et professeur à hec
messieurs merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation et je vous demande pardon
pour le retard l'édition précédente a
duré plus que prévu ce que nous
souhaitons c'est vous entendre dans un
exposé liminaire qui pourrait tenir si
cela est possible
en cinq minutes pour répondre aux
questions de base
pourquoi cette réforme quelle forme
nous avons des problèmes de dissipation
pardonnez moi quelle forme doit-elle
prendre cette réforme quels impôts
devrait être dans son champ et quel
résultat
peut-on en attendre donc dans un premier
temps vous répondez à ces trois
questions brièvement et ensuite je
donnerai la parole au rapporteur général
et qui qui pourra recadrés notre débat
et enfin celles et ceux qui souhaite
vous interroger auront la parole dans un
second temps alors peut-être que par
ordre alphabétique on pourrait donner la
parole d'abord à jean hervé lorenzi
ordonna je suis président
malheureusement si vous avez donné cinq
minutes heure je voudrais au fond dire
deux choses la première
la première j'ai gagné à côté de profs
donc les combats barbe
la première c'est que je suis comme
beaucoup de d'économies ce je me suis
retrouvée je suis pas spécifié fiscalité
mais je me suis retrouvé dans beaucoup
de groupes dont le groupe la cour des
comptes sur le rapprochement franco
allemand avec syndicaux ni son sort un
petit cahier sur la fiscalité
j'ai lu avec grand plaisir le livre de
thomas et ses deux camarades
donc tout ça au fond donnent le
sentiment que la proche de la réforme
fiscale par la fiscalité du patrimoine
est une absurdité intellectuelle pouvait
pas traiter le sujet alors vous voulez
que je dirais deux trois choses
positives sur ce thème là mais c'est
clair que le par exemple dans le dans le
groupe
la cour des comptes on a commencé où
chacun subodorer que ces avis ce rapport
c'était parce qu'il fallait traiter du
problème des sf et du bouclier fiscal
et puis des gens peu près normalement
constitué qui travaillent s'aperçoivent
que
fond le la le regard sur une fiscalité
aude nous amène à traiter de l'ensemble
des sujets donc remis reims p évidemment
le thème de la fiscalité ne peut pas
être abordée
j'en suis d'ailleurs tellement convaincu
suffit comme j'ai d'ailleurs écrit
quelque part que il n'y aura pas de
réformes fiscales en 2011 dont je me
réjouis vous même monsieur le président
vous avez abordé le thème à travers
l'épreuve du tva sociale
d'autres le traite à travers beaucoup à
travers des rapprochements de fiscalité
de direct traitez pas affiliée de
patrimoine est profondément insuffisant
est actuellement premier sujet donc je
suis farouchement opposé à l'idée qu'on
traite ce thème qui est majeur pour
notre pays dans la précipitation dans le
dans l'excitation deuxième sujet
lorsqu'on regarde la fiscalité avec de
la comparaison l'allemagne qui est
d'ailleurs un exercice aussi compliqué
parce que rien ne nous dit que
l'allemagne doit être en toutes choses
notre notre modèle est une sorte de
d'une identification en allemagne qui
est là aussi curieuse mais le rapport et
le travail très bien fait la cour des
comptes est évidemment ce n'est pas sur
le patrimoine que on peut juger tout
simplement parce que la fiscalité du
patrimoine allemande n'a rien à voir
avec celle des autres pays de céder donc
je vais dire si on doit regarder quelque
chose il vaut mieux regarder dans ce
domaine là on doit regarder que des gens
qui ont un rapport onu comme vous le
savez on est dans un rapport de 1 à 4
sur la fed la taxation du stock de
patrimoine dont on connaît tous sanaa là
aussi pas grand sens troisième sujet
pour nous autres économistes
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le fait
que vous avez reçue légende ocde il ya
d'ailleurs dans ce groupe à
le patron des petits fiscal c d e
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
un débat qu'on a depuis deux siècles
comment est ce que au fond on relit ce
qui m'intéresse croissance ce que c'est
le seul sujet qui à mon sens de mon
point de vue mérite que l'on se
concentre sur une infante fiscale
d'urgence je ne laisse pas dit que joyce
hatto mal soin de parler beaucoup
d'équité mais il va m'expliquer que
c'est la même chose mais sur le fond ce
thème là est un débat qui est teinté
débat très compliqué le cde nous donne
une recette de toutes fabriquées
vous savez les impôts sont plus ou moins
positif pour la croissance ce sont la
nature la fiscalité sur la consommation
etc cela vaut mieux donc il faut qu'on
augmente la tva c'est un vrai débat
mais il n'est pas tranchée par les
économistes il n'y a pas là aussi de
solutions n'y a pour moi j'ai un point
de vue qui est évidemment un point de
vue j'allais dire tout à fait
personnelle critiquable mais qui est
celui sur lequel je vais me battre dans
les semaines et mois qui viennent
sur le fond je pense que la société
française en deux secondes
est une société qui est en réalité très
dynamique où je suis j'explique avec un
très antique l'init je suis convaincu
que la fiscalité peut-être une manière
de tirer le sujet de manière j'allais
dire très très forte pourquoi mais vous
allez voir qu'on va retrouver la
fiscalité du patrimoine dans un instant
parce que en même temps ça près mme mack
reconnu très compliqué en même temps il
faut que nous réduisions notre dette
c'est à dire peut-être 30 à 40 milliards
de diminution des dépenses annuellement
ce qui est un problème exercice qui va
devenir compliqué pour l'exercice 2012
et 2013 en même temps il faut que nous
puissions dégager 30 à 40 milliards
d'investissements complémentaires qui
sont un investissement de long terme
risque et est destiné à se substituer en
termes d'activité économique aux
activités que nous comme les autres pays
de l ocde nous avons perdu en quatre
cinq ans en transfert vers les pays vers
les pays émergents
ceci m'amène à 2 deux remarques et deux
idées j'allais dire presque fixe
mais ça c'est l'âge qui veut ça la
première c'est qu'au fond je considère
que la fiscalité de du patrimoine
m'intéresse sur un sujet franchement
lisf le bouclier fiscal on en parlera
tout à l'heure mais ça m'intéresse pas
ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse
c'est d'abord ces epci le nesc 4
milliards sur 1000 sur 850 milliards de
de prélèvements obligatoires c'est une
plaisanterie c'est pas un sujet le sujet
clé c'est le suivant comment est ce que
je peux petit a essayé d'allonger
l'epargne de manière à ce que cette
épargne puisse puisse non pas doivent ne
puisse être éventuellement disponibles
pour des investissements qui est un
caractère plus risqués qui se d
investissement de long terme et parle de
long terme ne signifie pas on a les gens
prennent des parts de long terme dans le
pays donc quelle est la fiscalité qui me
favorise cela mais ça ne signifie pas
que j'ai résolu le deuxième problème qui
est celui de pouvoir investir dans des
activités qui sont des activités
risquées
or le sujet majeur de nos pays et d'une
autre c'est celui de la version risques
et c'est une aversion au risque qui va
pas diminuer avec le vieillissement de
nos sociétés donc un sujet il est
fiscalement petit 1 de pouvoir au fond
favoriser et réfléchir se concentrer sur
l'allongement de la fiscalité de
l'épargné c'est à dire des flux de du
patrimoine ça c'est le premier aspect et
deuxième aspect mais c'est un autre
sujet qui est fiscalement mais pas
directement liées à la fiscalité
patrimoine comment peut-on en réalité
faire que la collectivité l'état on peut
l'appeler comme on veut au fond prennent
une part du risque sur les
investissements qui sont des
investissements par mathieu de long
terme parce que c'est ça dont nous avons
besoin pour pouvoir investir dans les
années qui viennent
que ce soit pour les pme que ce soit
pour n'importe quoi mais on a besoin de
mes 30 40 milliards sinon notre problème
est un problème sans solution
macroéconomiques
deuxièmement comme je suis dit au fond
très anti déclinistes je crois que une
large partie de du problème de place
j'ai des choses de croissance d'un pays
c'est évidemment le règlement ou le
règlement la tentative de solution sur
l'emploi des jeunes
donc au ciel c'est la deuxième l'urgence
est donc au delà d'autres d'affaires qui
traite plutôt du marché du travail et du
contrat de travail unique qui sera un
sujet clé je considère qu' il faut
fluidifier fluidifier les transferts
intergénérationnels
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on considère
je peux me tromper ces chiffres sont
difficiles au fond à vérifier mais en
gros qui a une dizaine de milliards
d'euros qui descendent de la génération
n 1 génération elle moins 2 ou un peu
avant m + 2 et donc que ceci est très
insuffisant donc ceci repose revient à
dire que dans la fiscalité du patrimoine
le deuxième sujet le deuxième levier au
lieu de retraite rallier cfa près mais
le deuxième sujet c'est de regarder
l'équilibré entre les droits les taxes
et la succession aux successions et les
avantages donnés aux donations c'est si
on ne résout pas ce problème ont surtout
avec des gens qui touchent leur
succession qui touche là finalement le
l'héritage à mon âge qui est quand même
sympathique pour moi mais pas pour le
fonctionnement une société donc j'ai il
ya 2 2
le gic qui peuvent se mettre en place
la première à lons et est très
développée par quelqu'un de pa risque
économique c'est andré masson c'est à
dire petit a essayé d'inventer de
nouveaux process remettre le viager mais
refait à travers le système bancaire
mais ça ça prend un peu de temps et on
pourra en discuter tout à l'heure si
vous voulez et deuxième sujet
rééquilibrer je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus important
les droits qui sont les taxes qui sont
liées aux successions qui on était quand
même très très largement supprimés par
rapport aux des nations salaires par
tous les moyens faire que de l'argent
revienne vers les générations plus
jeunes c'est à mon sens les deux sujets
clés et je laisse à chebba qui le soin
de traiter de l' isf et du bouclier
fiscal qui sûrement et passionnant
projet qui est passionnant pour la
politique mais très peu pour l'activité
économique de notre pays
merci merci la parole est maintenant à
thomas piketty
merci bon moi je vais je vais quand même
essayer de dire quelques mots sur sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine et sur les sf et
la taxe foncière puisque apparemment
c'est le sujet du jour
je m'associe quand même très largement à
ce que ce que vient de dire j'en avais
sur le fait que ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas le vrai sujet enfin le vrai sujet de
notre système fiscal c'est de moderniser
et simplifier notre système d'imposition
directe des revenus qui est
incroyablement morcelé complexes
notamment sur la partie revenus de
l'épargné qui pratique toujours pas la
retenue à la source alors que tous nos
voisins le font depuis toujours les
vrais sujets ils sont là et on a un
système de financement de la protection
sociale qui repose trop fortement sur
les cotisations donc tous ces sujets et
visiblement ils viendront plus en 2012
que cette année comment on se retrouve
là parler de l'impôt sur la fortune
alors que autant que je sache personne
il ya un an avait envie de parler bon si
j'ai bien compris on ne se résout pas à
supprimer le bouclier fiscal de façon
sèche et on a besoin d'ajouter lorsque
je dis oui enfin il ya eu également
l'accès une accélération par exemple
fait mais qu'importe le sujet et la
parlons-en
donc moi je voudrais juste dire quelques
mots sur les différentes formes
d'imposition du stock de patrimoine
essentiellement des deux impôts sur le
patrimoine en france et dans un certain
nombre de pays historiquement si on
regarde un peu les choses qui sont
l'impôt sur la fortune la taxe foncière
et en un mot la thèse rapide que je
voudrais défendre
moins de cinq minutes c'est que si on
regarde les choses de façon technique et
aussi peu idéologique que possible on se
rend compte que l'impôt sur la fortune
techniquement est un impôt beaucoup plus
moderne que notre vieille taxe foncière
et que le supprimer pour se retrouver
nez à nez avec cette taxe foncière dont
le poids augmentera continuellement
serait une absurdité regard de
l'histoire
donc pourquoi je dis ça donc quelle est
la différence dans les deux cas on taxe
le stock de patrimoine que possèdent les
gens
dans un cas la taxe foncière on tape
simplement le patrimoine immobilier sur
des valeurs cadastrales quand pas été
revus comme on sait depuis 40 ans en
allemagne ses 70 ans
tant que c'est encore pire d'une
certaine façon mais on a donc cette
vieille taxe foncière qui qui qui repose
sur des valeurs qui sont extrêmement
ancienne l'impôt sur la fortune dans son
fonctionnement technique dans son
assiette et est imparfait comporte trop
de niches fiscales mais beaucoup plus
satisfaisant que la taxe foncière pour
au moins deux raisons premièrement on
prend les valeurs de marché au 1er
janvier
bon alors les gens doivent déclarer ce
qui est embêtant c'est vrai qu'on
préférerait avoir un système où les
valeurs cadastrales s'ajuste chaque
année avec des systèmes automatiques
avec des déclarations préremplies ce
serait formidable mais en attendant tant
qu'on sait pas faire ça visiblement on a
beaucoup de mal à réviser les valeurs
cadastrales c'est de la faute de
personne et de tout le monde à la fois
on a beaucoup de mains c'est ça je crois
qu'on peut tomber d'accord là dessus
mais à partir du moment où on a beaucoup
de mal et qu'on a plusieurs dizaines
d'années de retard sur la révision se
priver de cet outil au moins on déclare
les valeurs de ses biens immobiliers
chaque année au 1er janvier serait une
absurdité l'immense avantage quand même
de se baser sur les prix de marché
c'est qu'au moins en france ben
personnes contestent que quand on est au
dessus du seuil
donc mettons 800000 euros ben on est au
dessus du seuil quand on est en dessous
on est en dessous après on peut discuter
du niveau du seuil
on peut dire un million de millions ont
peu bougé le seuil et les taux autant
qu'on veut c'est un autre sujet qu'on
peut voir après mais au moins il n'y a
pas de contestation sur le fait que le
seuil oms on sait à peu près le mesurer
ce qui n'était pas du tout le cas dans
les impôts sur le patrimoine qui ont été
supprimés ces dix dernières années en
espagne en allemagne en suède et qui
n'ont rien à voir techniquement avec l'
isf français et là il ya des
comparaisons qui sont faites qui ce qui
dénote du niveau d'idéologie dans ces
débats et d'absence de connaissances
systèmes fiscaux étrangers qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est à dire que
dans tous ces pays allemagne espagne
suède regarder autant que vous voulez
c'est est basée sur des valeurs
cadastrales cirque les biens immobiliers
étaient pris en compte pour des valeurs
qui datait de plusieurs dizaines
d'années a tiré exactement comme
d'autres taxes foncières françaises
sauf que au moins la taxe foncière comme
c'est vaguement proportionnelle ça
touche tout le monde dont les gens sont
pas très contents que les valeurs
cadastrales varie un peu trop de commune
en commune mais ça passe à peu près
imaginez maintenant
qu'on utilise ces mêmes valeurs pour
savoir qui est au dessus de 800 mille
euros enfin ou d'un seuil quelconque
dans un système progressif
bon c'était ça le système en vigueur en
espagne en allemagne ou en suède cirque
on utilisait des valeurs cadastrales
variant de façon complètement arbitraire
suivant les communes et les quartiers
pour décider qui était au dessus du
seuil d'imposition ou pas et donc
c'était ça le débat évidemment ça
rendait fou tout le monde enfin imaginer
qu'on a on passe un système comme ça en
france ce serait complètement
insupportable de penser que suivant la
commune où on habite on est au dessus ou
en dessous et on paye ou non cet impôt
donc ça rend défoulement les juges ont
finit par s'emmêler ont dit qu'il y
avait une rupture caractérisée du
principe d'égalité devant l'impôt ce qui
était clairement le cas et ses impôts
ont été supprimés pour cette raison mais
pas du tout pour les raisons qu'on
évoque actuellement pour supprimer
l'impôt sur la fortune français tirent
personnes en allemagne se plaignait que
ça faisait fuir les gens au
liechtenstein en espagne que c'est le
zéphyr anders était pas le sujet du tout
le sujet c'était un problème d'équité
dont l'impôt face à un impôt qui était
très obsolètes dans son fonctionnement
pour une raison très simple la sépaq le
législateur français qu'en créant
l'impôt sur la fortune est beaucoup plus
malin que le législateur espagnol ou
allemand
c'est un plan que le législateur
français il agit dans les années 80 90
alors que les impôts sur le patrimoine
allemand espagnol suédois nous viennent
directement du 19e siècle comme la taxe
foncière sont des impôts qui sont
beaucoup plus ancien que notre impôt sur
la fortune bon ça c'est au moins
l'avantagé d'être à contre-courant
politiquement du reste du monde en
créant un impôt sur la fortune dans les
années 80 90 et qu'au moins on le fait
techniquement de façon mieux que les
impôts créer un siècle plus tôt parce
que tout simplement parce que dans les
années 80 90 on s'est rendu compte
depuis 1914 que l'inflation était un
phénomène durable que en particulier
l'inflation sur les prix des actifs
était un problème sérieux et que si on
voulait un impôt sur le patrimoine il
fallait avoir absolument des valeurs de
marché qui sont peut être imparfaite
mais qui au moins fournissent une base
objective deuxième grand avantage du
fonctionnement de l'impôt sur la fortune
par rapport à la taxe foncière c'est
évidemment la déduction des emprunts
immobiliers et à l'aspect complètement
fou de la taxe foncière c'est que si
vous êtes endettés vous avez un emprunt
immobilier de la même valeur
votre appartement vous avez un
appartement de 800000 euros à paris mais
vous avez un emprunt de 800 mille euros
ou même un emprunt plus élevé parce que
les prix immobiliers ont chuté ce qui
peut arriver
ce qui est beaucoup arrivée aux états
unis on se retrouvait avec des gens qui
avaient une valeur nette de patrimoine
négative qui re paient en intérêts plus
cher que ce qu'ils auraient payé en
loyer pour le même bien mais qui se
retrouvent à payer autant de taxes
foncières que quelqu'un qui n'a aucun
emprunt sur le dos puisqu'on n'y a
aucune prise en compte des emprunts au
moins dans l'impôt sur la fortune ont
déduit l'emprunt donc quelqu'un avec à
800000 euros d'emprunt avec huit cent
mille euros d'appartements à paris la 02
patrimoine il a même encore moins qu'il
ya 30% de l'abattement sur la résidence
principale dans tous les cas ils payent
pas l'impôt
bon et puis à partir du moment où vous
déduisez les emprunts et les passifs
financiers il est logique d'ajouter les
actifs financiers vous retrouvez
finalement avec un impôt je repasserai
nova qui est quand même beaucoup plus
intelligent dans son fonctionnement que
notre taxe foncière je pense être
comparaison elle doit être central dans
notre réflexion pourquoi parce que en
termes de masse de quoi parle-t-on on a
une taxe foncière qui rapportent presque
20 milliards d'euros bon mettons un peu
plus de 15 si on prend uniquement là par
ménage c'était quand même plus de trois
fois plus que l'impôt sur la fortune à
quatre et demi milliard d'euros il ya
beaucoup de pays dans le monde où la
taxe foncière est beaucoup plus élevé
qu'en france aux états unis au royaume
uni en proportion de la capitalisation
immobilière on serait à 25 milliards
environ de taxes foncières
est-ce qu'il faut supprimer un impôt sur
la fortune qui rapporte 5 pour se
retrouver avec une taxe foncière qui
rapportera finalement cinq de plus nous
dise de plus je pense que ce serait une
absurdité d'un point de vue technique et
qu'il faudrait au contraire plutôt
essayer de rapprocher l'assiette de la
taxe foncière de celle de la fortune en
envisageant des déductions d'emprunts
immobiliers en se basant on est en
essayant de passer aux valeurs de marché
mais nous les prenons ce qui existe oui
mais nous ne faisons rien laissons les
bases continuer 40 ans de plus si on
veut mais en attendant on a une système
techniquement qui fonctionne on peut
discuter autant qu'on veut sur les taux
réduire les taux diminuer les niches en
tout cas se priver de cet outil pour se
retrouver avec un impôt la taxe foncière
que personne ne s'est réformée jeu je
conclue juste un mot la comparaison avec
l'allemagne comme le rappelait jean
hervé est très très flou c'est d'abord
pour une raison simple c'est que
l'allemagne a des impôts sur le
patrimoine en particulier des impôts
fonciers qui sont beaucoup plus légers
que tous les autres pays pour une raison
simple aussi c'est que la capitalisation
immobilière allemande pour différentes
raisons est beaucoup plus faible en
proportion de la capitalisation
immobilière en fait c'est assez proche
de du cas français mais il faut quand
même faut quand même divisés parce que
si on décide si on ne prend on ne divise
pas et du point de vue du marché
immobilier la comparaison avec le
royaume uni londres par rapport à paris
est au moins aussi pertinente pour nous
que la comparaison avec l'allemagne donc
là je suis d'accord avec jean hervé que
la la focalisation sur l'allemagne et
pas la plus pertinente mais enfin dans
tous les cas si on fait ce type de
comparaison internationale
comparons ce qui est comparable les
impôts sur le patrimoine qui ont été
supprimés dans des pays européens ces
derniers n'ont rien à voir avec l'impôt
sur la fortune français c'est pas du
tout pour les mêmes raisons que ce qu'on
évoque aujourd'hui en france qui ont été
supprimés alors on peut quand même
vouloir supprimer l'impôt sur la fortune
français pour d'autres raisons
mais parlons de ces autres raisons et ne
brandissons passé exemple qui sont
techniquement totalement à côté de la
plaque si la parole est maintenant à
christian saint etienne donc il va y
avoir des points communs avec mes
collègues et des points majeurs de
différence donc sur sur des points
communs le premier le premier point
commun c'est effectivement que abordé la
réforme fiscale uniquement sous l'angle
de la réforme du patrimoine est
réducteur puisque les problèmes que nous
avons sont des problèmes globaux
ce qui n'empêchera pas que je dirai
ensuite que si on est bien d'accord sur
le fait qu'il faut aller vers une
réforme majeure de la fiscalité au plus
tard dans un an on peut avoir une
première étape dès ce printemps sous
certaines conditions
c'est à dire notamment d'inscrire cette
première étape dans une direction
d'ensemble qui soit cohérente cette
première remarque est en fait je
voudrais insister justement et ça
éclaire à ce que je dirais sur la
réforme du patrimoine je voudrais
insister sur les nécessités de la
réforme fiscale qu'il va falloir faire
en urgence dans un an
je pense même qu en urgence on devrait
la faire tout de suite je vous dire
pourquoi je pense d'abord que nous
sommes à la veille d'une crise des
finances publiques historique en france
quel que soit le président en 2002 en
2012 nous aurons une crise historique de
finances publiques
il n'est même pas certain que nous ne
l'ayons pas avant mais je pense que nous
avons devant nous une crise d'ampleur
comparable à celle de l'ancienne de la
faim d'ancien régime
et je vous rappelle que 80% des
révolutions politiques sont arrivés par
des crises de finances publiques
nous avons en fait un déficit structurel
qui est 6.2 pibe 120 milliards d'euros
et c'est donc l'ampleur de l'exercice
qui est devant nous et il va falloir
traiter le problème en urgence ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième ce qui a
été relativement peu évoquée jusqu'ici
et qui est pour pour moi centrale je
l'avais beaucoup évoqué dans le rapport
de 2005 que j'ai fait au cae avec
jacques le cacheux c'est que nous sommes
et il faut le regarder avec une totale
lucidité nous sommes dans une union
européenne qui est un champ clos de
concurrence fiscale et sociale
personnellement sur le plan stratégique
je considère que si si on regarde
l'avenir de la france qui est de mon
point de vue sur le plan stratégique
très menacé à court terme ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de
potentiel mais nous avons un avenir qui
est très menacée à court terme est il né
il est menacé pour vous donner de mon
point de vue c'est l'ensemble d'une
réflexion qui conduisent à une intuition
global on est menacé pour pour 5% au
maximum par la compétition venant de
chine
mais 95% de notre problème de
compétitivité globale vient de la
compétition fiscale et sociale à
l'intérieur de l'europe qui est en train
d idées notre pays de sa substance
productive et donc quand on fera cette
réforme fiscale d'ensemble
il faudra que l'objectif fondamental qui
sera assigné à cette réforme c'est de
reconstruire un système productif dans
ce pays
sachant que pour moi le
point clé de l'équité c'est que tout le
monde est un boulot toutes les études
sociologiques depuis 15 ans ne font que
confirmer ce qu'on savait depuis
toujours c'est à dire que la première
dignité de l'homme c'est d'avoir un
travail qui lui permettent de se
regarder dans une glace le matin sans
avoir honte et donc euros pour faire
cela c'est la seule façon de le faire
c'est de reconstruire un système
productif qui fonctionne dans le
contexte européen et le troisième
élément qui est fortement lié ce que je
viens de dire c'est que nous ne sommes
pas quand on fait une réforme fiscale
faut prendre en compte le contexte nous
ne sommes pas dans une économie agricole
de la fin du xviiie nous ne sommes pas
dans l'économie industrielle fermé de
1980 qui était quasi fermé encore je
vous rappelle qu'on avait le contrôle
des changes encore jusqu'en 1990 on l'a
complètement oublié d'enlever le
contrôle des changes en 1990
là on fait une réforme au début des
années 2010 à un moment où ce qui est
fondamental pour la création de
richesses et l'économie entrepreneuriale
de la connaissance et cette économie en
entrepreneuriat de la connaissance c'est
au fond tout ce que nous savons il y à
un collègue du conservatoire national
des arts et métiers qui a recensé les 25
produits technologiques que nous
utilisons tous autour de cette table que
vous utilisez tous en permanence au
téléphone
vos ordinateurs et le reste aucun des
produits en france donc on a loupé la
révolution sur le plan de la production
la révolution technologique de 10
numérique
on est en train de louper sur le plan de
la production celle des biotechnologies
on s'affaiblit dans les nanotechnologies
donc comment peut-on espérer rester une
grande puissance industrielle si on se
dote pas des moyens de remettre
l'entrepreneur au coeur de la
reconstruction notre système productif
alors ces éléments sont clés parce que
si on aborde de façon étroite la
question de la réforme fiscale en se
disant en gros
et surtout de façon morale en disant on
va faire payer telle ou telle catégorie
sociale particulièrement les riches on
court à l'échec
donc il y as besoin de rétablir une plus
grande équité dans le système parce
qu'effectivement notre système fiscal
est devenu un gruyère et il est exact
que compte tenu de ce gruyère les les
plus hauts revenus ont un taux de
fiscalité plus faible
en gros le 1% supérieure à un taux de
fiscalité plus faible que le deuxième
sans thil supérieur qui a lui-même un
taux de fiscalité plus faible le
troisième set il sachant qu'ensuite
heureusement ça s'inverse et on a des
taux de fiscalité qui baissent mais donc
il faut corriger le fait que le 1er 2e
sentent ils ont des taux de fiscalité
plus faible mais ça ça peut se faire
dans le cadre d'une réforme globale qui
doit concerner simultanément liesse la
tva lire pp jsf la csg et la cotisation
famille de 5 4% sur les salaires ça
c'est la réforme en réalité de mon point
de vue sur le plan de la compétitivité
économique si on était tous objectif on
devrait sonner le tocsin
c'est pas c'est pas en 2013 qu'il faut
faire cette réforme c'est aujourd'hui
tout cela étant rappelé si on veut faire
cette réforme du patrimoine tout de
suite comme première tranche de cette
réforme d'ensemble que j'ai évoqué alors
il ya néanmoins des pistes qu'on peut
regarder mais c'est uniquement dans
cette direction là si c'est une première
étape dans la réforme globale alors de
ce point de vue ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que si l'on devait aller vers
une suppression du bouclier fiscal il
est incontestable que s'accélérera la
délocalisation d'une partie du
patrimoine national
ou en tout cas des entrepreneurs qui
sont des acteurs clés de ce qu'on attend
c'est à dire une reconstruction du
système productif donc si on supprime le
bouclier fiscal il faut réfléchir la
nature de l'impôt sur la fortune que
l'on maintient première remarque
deuxième remarque l'observation du débat
en cours me conduit à penser que nous ne
sommes pas prêts à supprimer les sf
troisième remarque du débat de ce que
j'observe aujourd'hui c'est que un des
problèmes majeurs de l'isf aujourd'hui
ce sont ces taux qui ont été institués à
une époque de forte inflation
quand vous aviez une des rangs d'une
période où vous aviez de l'inflation à 5
7 % des taux à 1 8 ne posaient pas
problème mais et ça si vous retenez
seulement ce point ses centrales
aujourd'hui si vous prenez les trois
principaux éléments du capital en france
aujourd'hui dans le monde
les actions les obligations et
l'immobilier l'immobilier parisien un
rendement net après impôts aujourd'hui y
compris entre 2 et 2 et demi pour cent
le capital obligataire après impôts à un
rendement autour de deux et demi 3 % et
les actions les dividendes perçus
représente un revenu autour de deux et
demi à 3% de telle sorte que si on
devait maintenir l' isf
je pense qu'il faudra aller vers une
structure qui serait la suivante un
impôt qui ne peut pas dépasser 2 me
d'abord un impôt qui devrait démarrer 3
millions d'euros je ne pense pas qu'il
soit raisonnable de d'imposer
plus bas ce qui du coup supprime toute
discussion sur l'abattement sur la
résidence principale
je pense qu'il faut pas toucher à
l'abattement de 30% si on règle la
question des taux et si on règle la
question du point de démarrage c'est à
dire que si vous avez un point de
démarrage de lier cfa 3 millions à ce
moment là vous n'avez plus besoin de
toucher l'abattement sur la résidence
principale et vous n'avez plus vous avez
beaucoup moins de problèmes liés au fait
que les classes moyennes supérieures
vivent dans les grandes villes
françaises sont aujourd'hui imposées à
liez f alors qu'il n'y a aucune raison
qu'elle le soit objectivement contenu
delà du poids global de l'imposition
dans notre pays et ensuite on aurait un
deuxième taux alors selon que vous
mettez le point de démarrage de liesse f
à 3 millions ou admis on pourrait avoir
une première tranche qui pourrait être
de deux à vingt millions ou de 3,30
millions qui sera à 0 5% et au delà de
20 millions ou de 30 millions vous
auriez une tranche marginale qui serait
de 0 75% qui représenterait en gros le
quart entre le quart et le tiers du
rendement effectif du capital investi
aujourd'hui en france sachant que ça
représenterait le tiers du rendement ce
rendement ayant déjà payé un impôt sur
le revenu alors se pose à ce moment là
la question du financement de cette
mesure
je prends reprendrait pour si on devait
faire une économie de ceux de ce système
aujourd'hui l' iss net de bouclier coûte
3 2 milliards d'euros
si on mettait en place cette mesure
elle coûterait c'est vous qui le
déterminerait mieux que moi mais entre
1,2 et 1,5 milliard d'euros or ce que
l'on pourrait imaginer c'est compensé
par deux mesures qui seraient centrées
sur les détenteurs de
de très beaux patrimoines d'une part
passer le taux marginal de l'impôt sur
le revenu de 41 à 43 % pour les revenus
au delà de cent mille euros par part
d'une part et d'autre part reprend d'une
mesure qui a été proposée qui concerne
l'application du régime des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux pour tout bien
immobilier sur le territoire national
qui étant de nature à rapporter 600
millions de doro donc vous auriez une
réforme qui serait financée si vous
deviez faire une première étape au
printemps mais si on va vers une réforme
globale que je présenterai dans un livre
qui sort le 7 avril
quelle heureuse émulation quelle
réjouissance yale réjouissant si on va
dans la direction d'une réforme globale
de mon point de vue dans une réforme
globale
on va devoir jouer massivement sur la cg
et la tva pour obtenir les objets pour
atteindre les objectifs suivants
d'une part ce que j'observe au plan
européen il faut que vous soyez
extrêmement attentif à cela
au delà du sujet du jour qui est la
réforme du patrimoine mais notamment
pour les grands responsables qui sont
ici présents de la commission des
finances du sénat qui sont tous les deux
des spécialistes et avec tous leurs
collègues de fiscalité c'est que vous
avez un mouvement général de
augmentation de la tva dans tous les
pays d'europe
servant à financer une baisse du taux d
s c'est à dire que ce que l'allemagne a
initié en 2007 est en train de se
généraliser et vous avez par exemple
regarder notamment si vous observez
analysé clairement ce que cette
évolution le pays qui va se rode qui va
se retrouver en position centrale qui
représentera le mieux le système fiscal
européen va être la finlande qui va être
exactement dans la moyenne de ce qui se
prépare sur la base de choses déjà
annoncées par les gouvernements
européens
c'est à dire une situation dans laquelle
le taux de tva sera à 23% et que la
hausse du taux de tva en finlande
finance une baisse du taux dit s
sachant que cette baisse du taux 10 ans
peut être peut être réservé aux aux
bénéfices mis en réserve puisque j'ai
écouté la fin de l'intervention de
christian noyer ce matin il ya un
serpent de mer qui est le prêt aux pme
en france
il a rappelé à juste titre que le taux
moyen de prêts en france aujourd'hui aux
pme était de 40 centimes en dessous de
la moyenne des autres pays mais à aucun
moment il n'a dit que ce qui bloquait en
réalité le fait qu'on donne plus
d'argent aux pme c'est l'insuffisance
criante de leurs fonds propres et que
donc si on veut que les banques prêtent
davantage
et bien comme elles sont
particulièrement sensibles au ratio
d'endettement sur fonds propres
on a une nécessité absolue de
reconstituer la base de fonds propres de
nos pme pour leur permettre de se
financer et de financer la
reconstruction du capital productif qui
est nécessaire dans notre pays donc un
mot de conclusion
ma préférence ne va pas une réforme
partielle de liesse de l' isf
je sais néanmoins que la pression
politique va faire que l'on va devoir en
faire une si on doit faire une réforme
partielle de la fiscalité du patrimoine
je ne recommence je recommanderais de
faire une réforme qui élimine les
principaux inconvénients de cet impôt
sachant que dans la réforme globale qui
s'impose absolument notre pays
le lit et zef devra normalement être
totalement supprimée et remplacée par
une tranche supérieure de l'impôt sur le
revenu qui est qui qui qui d'ailleurs
qui d'ailleurs et c'est mon dernier mot
qui d'ailleurs pourrait continuer de
bénéficier du mécanisme actuel en place
pour le financement des pme
vous avez un mécanisme aujourd'hui qui
est associé à liez de financement d'une
chaire à les pme et ils pourraient être
conservés pour la tranche supplémentaire
d'impôt sur le revenu qui se
substituerait à l'iesf merci monsieur
david tech pas
les marolles je vais faire mon possible
pour essayer de tenir en cinq minutes
comme comme mes collègues non je vais
juste faire de points donc le premier
point le premier point est un constat de
diagnostic en fait qui relève du rapport
donc moi je suis pas un expert de la
fiscalité au sens large mais j'ai rédigé
avec olivier garnier un rapport sur le
sur le patrimoine des ménages français
et notamment sur sa fiscalité donc je
vais me concentrer sur la fiscalité du
patrimoine
même si je rejoins jean hervé sur le
fait qu'effectivement c'est probablement
pas pas le seul sujet donc le premier
constat le constat sur la fiscalité du
patrimoine c'est que c'est horriblement
compliqué qu'il ya beaucoup de véhicules
de d'épargné réglementée et que en fait
sous tous ces dispositifs extrêmement
compliqué se neutralisent les uns et les
autres c'est à dire que vous avez 40
quasiment la moitié de l'héparine des
ménages français est investi en épargne
non risqués avec incitations fiscales et
un tiers et et 10 % de l'épargné des
ménages français est investi en et par
une risqué avec incitations fiscales
donc vous avez des dispositifs qui
cherchent à inciter d'un côté les gens à
avoir de l'epargne risqués et de l'autre
les gens à voir des pailles non risqués
de même que vous avez des dispositifs
qui cherchent à inciter les gens à voir
de l' épargne bloquée et d'autres qui
cherchent à inciter les gens à avoir de
l'épargné liquide comme le livret a vous
avez vous avez un maquis de systèmes qui
qui ont qui ce qui rentre en conflit les
uns avec les autres et dont le résultat
total est à peu près neutre voire même
légèrement défavorable à l'héparine
risquer l épargne en actions selon une
étude du trésor
donc premier point traîne une grande
complexité qui a d'ailleurs pour un
pacte une effet de redistribution à
l'envers comme vous avez beaucoup de
niches fiscales bah voilà il faut il
faut pouvoir en bénéficier pour
bénéficier du scellier parfois déjà
avoir un certain niveau de rumeurs de
revenus et de patrimoine pour se payer
un conseiller fiscal pour essayer
d'optimiser sa alors que d'un côté vous
cherchez à soumettre un certain nombre
de revenus du patrimoine à une
à une fiscalité progressive à celle de
lire pp de l'autre vous voulez soumettez
à une fiscalité dégressive par le biais
de l'évasion fiscale donc à nouveau là
vous avez deux objectifs qui sont
poursuivis en même temps et à nouveau
l'accumulation de priorité traduit le
manque total de priorités globales
donc voilà pour finir en ce qui concerne
l'épargné réglementée son efficacité
généralement est assez peu prouver elles
manquent ils ferment complètement
d'évaluation est ce que vraiment on a
besoin de l'argent collecté par le
livret a pour financer le logement
social à tour à taux préférentiel est ce
que vraiment les pme françaises sont
rationnées sur le marché du crédit' de
manière pathologique par rapport à
l'europe dans les enquêtes
internationales c'est pas net
est ce que les pme françaises on est ce
que est ce que les fc pays est ce que
les dispositifs le dispositif isf en
faveur des pme vraiment on est dans vos
va vraiment créer vraiment susciter
l'émergence de pme développer c'est pas
du tout évident ou en tout cas on peut
on ne peut rien enfin on n'a pas en a
pas donné d'information là dessus très
précises
donc voilà donc au milieu de ceux de
cette complexité énorme qui aboutit à
peu près à rien on a deux problèmes on
en a un problème essentiel il ans qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas résolu qui est
celui de l'épargne-retraite donc
donc vous avez vous avez un un motif
d'intervention d'intervention de l'état
à travers la fiscalité qui est qui est
clairement bien défini qui est celui
donc d'inciter les gens à se constituer
les par une retraite parce que
spontanément ils le font pas
suffisamment encore nokia un motif
paternaliste qui qui est qui et qui est
légitimée par la recherche existantes et
donc c'est d'epargne à très long terme
donc c'est l'épargné à 30 ans dont on
parle plutôt du perco que de l'assurance
vie évidemment est bon les encours là
qui sont qui sont collectés par
par le perco sont microscopiques je
crois qu'à un milliard de milliards
quelque chose comme ça c'est ça n'existe
pas donc donc donc l'enjeu de lait par
une retraite c'est important pour les
gens ça peut être potentiellement aussi
important pour pour à nouveau là alors
là pour l'investissement de long terme
voire stabiliser le capital des
entreprises françaises via un effet
volume c'est-à-dire que dans les pays où
vous avez des fonds de pension ou en
tout cas des fonds de pension qui sont
soit privé soit soit public mais de
manière générale l'accumulation d'une
épargne retraite soit soit directement
par les individus soit en leur nom par
par la puissance publique
vous avez typiquement un niveau de
patrimoine des ménages qui à peu près à
5 fois le pib en france vous avez trois
fois le pib
donc il ya 2 2 2 pib deux années de
revenu national à peu près 4000
milliards d'euros en france qui pourrait
être collectées si vraiment on avait un
système qui avait il y avait plus de
capitalisation à nouveau ça ne veut pas
forcément dire que système de
capitalisation soit individuel il peut
être collectif mais en tout cas où il y
ait de l'épargné et donc ça ça
permettrait de générer davantage
d'epargne d'abord davantage d'épargnants
fonds propres d'avantagé panne risqué
pour les entreprises françaises
et puis pour les entreprises
internationales donc ça ça aurait
beaucoup d'impact juste un petit point
quand on compare les différents pays
quand on regarde par exemple les pays
qui investissent à très long terme comme
la norvège par exemple ou où les pays où
les fonds de pension sont importants
versus les pays comme la france où il ya
beaucoup moins d'épargné à long terme
la proportion du volume total d'épargné
qui est dévoué aux actions et la même
d'accord donc au total ce que vous avez
c'est une augmentation une augmentation
si vous voulez homothétique pour
utiliser un terme de 2 2 de mad su ou
avant même
vous avez une augmentation homothétique
de la fraction en tout cas du
portefeuille c'est à dire que c'est très
difficile pour un état même s'ils
insistent sur les parkings de long terme
pour augmente d'augmenter la fraction de
l'epargne qui va être dévoué au en
revanche il peut augmenter le volume
d'accord donc là c'est la hausse est là
où il ya une grosse différence
physiquement entre la hollande et la
france par exemple
toutes proportions gardées évidemment la
hollande qui a par exemple des fonds de
pension donc voilà donc qu elle l
approche que je préconise face à ce
double constat à la fois d'une
complexité excessive et d'objectifs qui
sont pas atteints donc c'est une
approche de simplification de la
fiscalité du patrimoine
donc quand on va parler de
simplification va parler d'augmenter
certains impôts par rapport à en baisser
d'autres à nouveau c'est je raisonne à
revenus constants donc il s'agit pas
d'augmenter la pression fiscale globale
1 il s'agit de tout ce qui va être
gagnés sur la collecte d'impôts va être
traduit par la disparition d'un autre
donc il ya deux deux versions la
première qui est une version qui est une
version timide qui était celle du
rapport avec olivier garnier
probablement plus réaliste même si elle
va vous sembler déjà relevant largement
de la science fiction c'est de supprimer
toutes les parades réglementer toutes
les niches diverses et variées et de
taxer le revenu du patrimoine 150
milliards d'euros selon le dernier
rapport du conseil des impôts et
prélèvements obligatoires 150 milliards
d'euros 24 milliards de dhs impôt sur le
patrimoine ont vu 10 et 24 par 150 ça
fait 15 % à peu près vous mettez une
taxe de 15% sur tous les revenus du
patrimoine
quelle que soit l investissement après
on peut moduler un petit peu ce taux
l'augmenter un peu pour financer des
incitations fiscales l épargne de long
terme
voilà c'est ça c'est si on veut si on
veut ajouter un petit élément
redistributif on peut mettre un
abattement de 500 euros sur le revenu
annuel du patrimoine manière a répliqué
l'aspect redistributif du livret a donc
ça c'est la première version c'est la
version timide il ya la version
ambitieuse qui consiste à supprimer
à supprimer les droits de mutation
divers et variés la taxe foncière
tous les impôts sur le revenu du capital
et tout asseoir sur
sur l'assiette de l'is f c'est à dire
sur sur le patrimoine donc vous avez
l'impôt total l'impôt total lever
l'impôt total sur le patrimoine incluant
les droits de mutation enfin la taxe
foncière et puis les revenus et les
revenus du patrimoine c'est 65 milliards
par an le patrimoine des français c'est
10 milliards 5,5 milles de résidence
principale 10 min dans non accès à cinq
mille résidences principales et 5000 de
l'immobilier locatif et puis
d'investissements financiers donc dix
mille dix mille milliards soixante cinq
65 / 10000 ça fait 0 65 vous avez un
taux de 0 65 surtout le patrimoine et
plus d'impôts surplus d'impôt sur le sur
le patrimoine
voilà donc ça c'est la version
évidemment ambitieuse elle sert
essentiellement à attirer votre
attention sur le besoin de
simplification de la taxation du
patrimoine et aussi sur son caractère
faisable sur son caractère faisable à
budget constant et relativement peu
impressionnant finalement puisque 0 soit
0,65 s'est pas non plus monstrueux voilà
merci
ah oui là tu es tout bien merci
messieurs merci d'avoir respecté
chacun des cinq minutes car à la vérité
nous n'avons pas vu le temps passer
2 2 2 grand enseignement c'est que notre
système fiscal est perfectible et le
second c'est que la fiscalité du
patrimoine n'est qu'un aspect de la
fiscalité
ayant dit cela je donne la parole au
rapporteur général
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
ne sais pas si la réforme avec lequel
nous allons sans doute au cd sera une
excellente réforme et je suis certain
que le débat tel qu'il commence à
s'instaurer devient un excellent débat
et nous vous en sommes collectivement au
diable et ma première question s'adresse
à l'ensemble des participants
un peu plus haut au professeur piketty
je ne reviens pas sur la taxe foncière
sur les préconisations de réforme de la
taxe foncière car nous ne sortons pas
encore de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
et par ailleurs nous n'oublions pas
particulier autour de cette table que la
taxe foncière est le seul impôt local
pure entre guillemets et que détricoter
et cet impôt et nous exposerait à un
grand nombre de mes comptes mais j'en
reviens sur les comparaisons au sein de
l' ocde et en rappelant que notre
première audition sous la présidence de
jean arthuis et nous a mis en présence
des responsables du centre de politique
et d'administration fiscales de l'os et
des yeux
qu'est ce que l'on a constaté la france
est le pays qui a le plus d'impôts
l'échantillon qui prélève plus et c'est
le pays nous dit l' ocde qui
pratiquerait la plus forte progressivité
c'est le pays où les taux nominaux
apparaissent les plus élevés tant pour
l'imposition du revenu que du capital en
revanche c'est un pays dont les bases
d'imposition sont assez basses compte
tenu du phénomène que nous connaissons
bien des niches fiscales et en allant un
peu plus loin
monsieur owens mettait en regard les
taux implicite d'imposition de la france
et de l'allemagne et en prenant une
référence 2008 et il nous fait il
considérait que le travail était imposé
à 41 4% en france et à 39% en allemagne
le capital disait-il à 38,8 pour ça en
france et 23,1 pour cent en allemagne et
la consommation à 19% de part et d'autre
donc un pays qui dépensent plus qu'ils
prélèvent plus mais qui semble selon l'
ocde
peut-être nous direz vous ce que vous en
pensez mais l'os et 2e n'est pas une
officine idéologique cc c'est une chose
que l'on a en commun qui en principe
travaille sur des statistiques
officielles bref voilà ce que nous
disait monsieur owens tout ma question à
monsieur piketty et
et qui est alimenté aussi par la lecture
de son intéressant ouvrage
révolutionnaire n'est ce pas et ma
question et monsieur le professeur est
ce que vos travaux prennent vraiment en
compte le fait que la compétitivité
fiscale est une nécessité pour notre
pays
c c c c est une question qui me semble
se poser et si je ne me trompe le
professeur saint-etienne nous a dit que
son paradis fiscal à lui était plutôt en
finlande alors votre paradis à vos
professeurs piketty est ce que vous
pouvez nous le décrire et où est il
d'autre part est là pour l'ensemble des
membres du panel et quelles réflexions
nous conseillez-vous pour retrouver une
logique économique dans l'échelle de
thau l'échelle des taux de l' isf alors
plusieurs d'entre vous ont abordé ce
sujet ne peut-on tendre vers une échelle
qui se réfèrerait je vais dire se
réfèrerait automatiquement à des taux de
marché représentative des rendements des
différentes classes d'actifs
est ce que c'est une réflexion qui vous
semblent pouvoir être poursuivis et j'en
viens à un aspect qui est peut-être un
peu plus sociétale et qui est commun en
réalité à l'impôt sur le revenu et aux
impôts sur le patrimoine et le
professeur piketty fait l'éloge de la
taxation des revenus individuels et il
se réfère à un modèle largement anglo
saxons qui frappe d'une imposition
chaque revenu
le système français
à cet égard est différent puisqu'il
repose sur le quotient familial est un
système qui fait du quotient familial
un élément clé de de la démarche fiscale
de la stratégie fiscale est aussi un
système qui réserve une place
particulière à la résidence principale
qu'on peut considérer que sans que ces
notions soit identique il y a si je puis
dire il y à un ensemble commun mais il y
a un lien entre les modes de vie la
famille sa stabilité et la résidence
principale sans que je puisse aller plus
loin et décrire ce lien et d'ailleurs je
ne suis pas un scientifique vous voulez
être donc vous êtes certainement
beaucoup mieux placé pour commenter ce
type de choses mais est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas aller plus loin si l'on
voudrait être pleinement cohérent et
considérer que l'impôt sur le patrimoine
devrait être aussi familialiser est ce
que c'est une voie de recherche que pour
les uns ou pour les autres il faudrait
suivre alors je termine sur un aspect
qui a été évoqué à mon avis est déjà
fort bien qu'ils aient la fiscalité de
l'épargné finalement entendre au moins
trois d'entre vous et c'est bien là
qu'il faudrait se poser des questions
sérieuses allonger la durée des
placements mieux contribuer au
financement stable des entreprises ce
qui veut sans doute dire revisiter nos
deux grandes spécificités que sont les
pains de réglementer d'une part et
l'assurance vie de l'autre si l'on
raisonne en masse alors et quels sont
les les les préconisations que vous
feriez j'ai bien entendu celle de
monsieur desmare infiné et est ce que
vous pensez et qu'il est possible
d'intégrer dans le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu
la taxation de tous les revenus de
l'épargné et en tenant compte sans doute
d'aspe sociaux d'un côté et de la durée
des placements de l'autre voilà pour
l'essentiel quelques questions posées au
panel mais en vous remerciant vivement
de vos contributions et tandis que vous
parliez successivement il était très
intéressant non seulement de vous
entendre mais d'observer les expressions
des autres intervenants
lorsque le collègue parlait voilà qui va
vous occuper quelques minutes monsieur
piketty d'abord s'il voulait bien
physique et fiscales ben moi je suis
ravi de répondre à des questions sur mon
livre je n'avais pas voulu en faire la
publicité comme ça directement mais
puisque vous m'offrez la possibilité je
ne vais pas il ya toujours un prix il a
raté mais et je le dédicace à la sortie
avec plaisir mais mais vous savez que
chaque année le sénat des livres à prix
du livre économique parfait voilà on est
trois voies sortir des livres donc à ce
président n'y aura pas de régime
donc bon malheureusement je vais par le
temps de vous faire une présentation
d'ensemble mais je vais essayer de
répondre à la question
première question de de philippe marini
non je vais prendre les choses dans le
sens inverse si vous avez fini sur la
fiscalité des revenus de patrimoine et
je dois dire que un des objectifs de la
de la réforme qu'on propose aux
objectifs centraux de la forme qu'on
propose dans ce livre c'est notamment de
simplifier tout le volet fiscalité des
revenus de patrimoine à dire que
propose-t-on en gros dans ce livre là la
proposition centrale c'est de
reconstruire nouvel impôt sur le revenu
comme une extension de la csg avec un
barème progressif pour simplifier notre
diagnostic c'est de dire on a un impôt
sur le revenu officielle qui désormais
prélève pratiquement deux fois moins que
la csg qui est un impôt sur le revenu
proportionnelle on a un niveau de mitage
de notre impôt sur le revenu qui va
kiffer nous notre diagnostic c'est qu'on
ne pourra plus réformer cet impôt sur le
revenu si on regarde l'évolution de ses
recettes sur longue période
on est aujourd'hui à à peine 2 5% du
pib' un lait des fois les gens quand ils
lui dirent 3% 4 % en un an ça diminue
continuellement là on est à 50 milliards
d'euros pour 2 milliards de pipe 2 5% du
pib' 1 dans tous les pays européens on
est à 7 8 10 points de pipe 3 4 fois
moins il ya 20 ans 25 ans on était à
cinq points de pipes et en 1990 il y
avait 120 en était à peu près quatre
points et demi de pudeur c'est très
simple les recettes c'était les mêmes
nominalement c'était 50 milliards
d'euros sauf que le pib était de 1000
milliards donc quand vous avez un un
taux dont le poids est divisée par deux
en vingt ans alors qu évidemment
l'ensemble des prélèvements obligatoires
malheureusement n'ont pas pu être divisé
par deux et on n'est pas près de pouvoir
les divisé par deux et ils sont
globalement stables donc quand vous avez
au sein de ce système fiscal un impôt
dans le premier vol devrait même
s'interroger et nuno diagnostic c'est
que cet impôt est tellement mité par les
niches la complexité
qu'il ne peut plus être réformé et qu'il
faut notre stratégie de réforme elle est
simple c'est de le supprimer purement et
simplement et de concevoir le nouvel
impôt comme une extension de la csg avec
un barème progressif
ce qui a le mérite d'utiliser ceux qui
existent et qui marche à savoir l'impôt
prélevé à la source qui est la csg avec
une assiette relativement large qui est
imparfaite
d'ailleurs qui était attendu par un
petit peu chaque année dans un on a
encore vu sur l'assurance-vie récemment
il ya toujours des mesures à prendre
pour étendre un peu l'assiette en tout
cas quand même une assiette notamment du
point de vue des revenus du patrimoine
qui est quand même beaucoup plus
satisfaisante
à tel point que d'ailleurs le comble le
conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
que si tu es d'avis de confond cette
assiette avec l'assiette des revenus
économiques et alors que l'assiette des
revenus économiques du patrimoine est
quand même plus élevé que l'assiette csg
il faut toujours reprendre les comptes
nationaux pour calculer l'assiette total
qui quand même plus élevé que la csg
enfin il reste que l'assiette cg est
large et utiliser cette assiette pour
baser le barème progressif totale de
l'impôt sur le revenu nous semble la
façon la plus simple de procès est donc
l'objectif et jean vient la question
compétitivité c'est d'abord un objectif
de simplification parce qu'on a un
système fiscal français qui est
extraordinairement complexe qui
affichent des taux statutaire supposée
très élevé mais en fait avec derrière
une telle ribambelle de déductions
d'abattement rendez vous compte comme ça
veut dire ce que ça veut dire quand on
dit que l'impôt sur revenu rapportent
deux fois moins que la csg ça veut dire
qu'on pourrait remplacer entièrement
l'impôt sur le revenu avec 4 points 4
points et demi de cg un point ces 12
milliards et 4.8 cg vous remplacer
entièrement l'impôt sur le revenu et
c'est tout mon temps à soi disant à 41%
donc ça donne une idée quand même du
niveau de mitage et d'absurdités du
système quelque part d'où notre
proposition assez radicale et qui permet
sur les revenus du patrimoine d'avoir un
système très simple avec quand même une
différence avec avec ce que proposait
des sports de vitesse mère d'une
certaine façon proposait de sortir
complètement la taxation des revenus de
patrimoine et la taxation des revenus du
travail donc sciemment l'impôt
progressif concernerait uniquement les
revenus du travail et les revenus 80
auraient un taux unique 15%
nous ça nous semble une mauvaise idée
notamment pour des questions
d'équité mais aussi d'efficacité c'est à
dire que l'expérience de tous les pays
qui ont des systèmes duo comme ça
d'imposition c'est qu'on a énormément
d'optimisation fiscale à la frontière
revenus du patrimoine revenus du travail
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
professions vous pouvez re et rappeler
certains fruits tangibles en mai du
revenu c'est vraiment la très mauvaise
idée
et si on veut minimiser les distorsions
et là sur sion fiscal on a intérêt à
voir la reine progressif qui s'applique
de la même façon à tous les revenus
quelles que soient leurs intitulés
juridique un et nous c'est exactement ce
qu'on propose puisqu'on prend dans un
premier temps après on peut l'étendre
l'assiette de la csg et on lui applique
un barème progressif
alors après on propose un barème
spécifique dont chacun a le droit d'être
d'être d'être en désaccord avec le
barème ça tombe bien puisque on donne la
possibilité à chabloz le tableau version
libérale version médiane version wii
mais inventer en d'autres si vous voulez
puisque je vois là on a depuis deux
semaines 370000 simulation qui ont été
effectuées en ligne par des personnes
contesté différents barèmes
donc nous on n'est pas bon voilà on
propose un barème pour mettre quelque
chose de précis sur la table la limite
si les gens pouvaient se mettre d'accord
sur la réforme d'ensemble de structure
et puis après et chacun propose un
barème différent d'être parfait donc ne
nous focalisons pas sur le barème je
mentionne simplement que le barème qu'on
propose permet des taux extrêmement
réduit jusqu'à des niveaux de revenus
quand même très élevé c'est à dire qu'on
est donc proposé un barème où on est à
10 % à 2000 euros brut par mois donc
revenus du capital compris à 13% à 5000
euros et à 25% à 10000 euros brut par
mois tout ça incluant la csg de 8%
donc par rapport à la csg crds de 8% à
2000 euros ajoute simplement 2% à 5
milles en rajoute 5%
donc on a quand même quelque chose qui
est d'une simplicité d'une lisibilité
avec des taux quand même très réduit
pour l'immense majorité des personnes
après chacun peut choisir un autre
barème trouvé que les taux montent trop
belle trop haut au delà de dix mille
euros par mois les réduire ça vous
obligera les augmenter sur les classes
moyennes dont chacun choisit de barèmes
qui veut ne nous disputons pas là dessus
mais en tout cas l'objectif central
ici puisque c'était ce à votre question
c'est d'abord un objectif de
simplification radicale d'abord et avant
tout pour la compétitivité vous savez
bon alors pour reprendre votre question
finir ma réponse en bouclant avec votre
question initiale sur le votre audition
donc ces vieilles de monsieur os de l'
ocde
moi je veux pas polémiquer avec monsieur
white je suis d'accord dans le fond que
la france affiche des taux statutaire
très élevé avec en vérité une preuve une
progressivité faible et qu'il faut
simplifier radicalement et réduire les
taux pour l'immense majorité des
contribuables et avoir une
simplification du système
maintenant il n'y a pas main chiffres
que vous avez cité monsieur owens
annonçant apparemment un taux de
taxation du capital de 38% en france et
de 20 3% en allemagne
alors là qui me paraît totalement en
dehors du tableau qui ne correspond
absolument pas à ce que tout le monde
peut trouver en se connectant à eurostat
qui publie chaque année dans ses
rapports des taux de taxation globaux du
capital dans tous les pays européens
vous ne trouverez absolument pas ça
est-ce qu'il l'a dit est ce qu'il n'a
pas dit s qu'il a rajouté un chiffre je
ne sais pas mais je peux vous dire que
ce chiffre est faux c'est à dire que
vous ne m'avez pas qu'il indique la
publication je n'en connais pas qui
indique ça et c'est faux on a des taux
de globo de prélèvement par ta chambre
te sort qui sont beaucoup plus proches
qui sont beaucoup plus proches entre
pays que d'un tel différentiel je compte
15 points en étant classé pas la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères dans
les impôts sur le club du oui alors s'il
refait sa classification en prenant pas
vous l'avantagent moi je mène également
la taxe d'habitation dans les impôts sur
le capital
ah ça c'est intéressant sauf si vous
êtes locataire vous avez un impôt sur le
capital auxquelles ce n'est pas de
capital grâce à ces objections nous
apprenons énormément vous savez on a
l'envié
ils font des comparaisons
internationales il ya forcément des
conventions oui non mais attends et
quand même la différence non moi
j'insiste comme ça il ya toujours des
conventions chacun a le droit de choisir
les conventions qui veut à condition
qu'elles soient explicites et
disponibles publiquement l'avantagent
des données d'eurostat tu sais qu'on
connaît leurs méthodes
prélèvement qui classe les avantages de
toutes les données qu'on sortait en
particulier ont refait dans ce livre une
analyse serrée des taux de taxation
justement du capital du travail c'est
que tout est en ligne sur le site
révolution fiscale point fr chacun peut
trouver toutes les données tous les
programmes que chacun les prennent les
améliore mais on ne peut pas juste citer
des chiffres comme ça en l'air je je je
n'ai pas tant je sais pas si je dois
vous répondre sur l'aspect individuel
quotient familial
c'est un grand sujet un passionnant à
venir jean hervé lorenzi vous avez eu de
remarques
la première c'est que les chiffres qu'on
va sortir qu'au décompte tente pas du
tout ces six chiffres là mêmes monsieur
owens est un farceur sur ces chiffres
n'ont pas simplement un farceur phare
sur la mobilité
je voudrais juste vous avez senti qu'on
était évidemment pas d'accord tous les
cas bien ce qui sauf sur un point c'est
que le sujet de l' isf est un sujet de
nature secondaire je voudrais juste
revenir sur un point d accord que que
j'ai avec thomas et un point d'accord
que j'ai ridé vite en raid et moi je
sais que vous avez que nous avons trois
sujets à régler trois a pas 36 le
premier s'est jugée hors idée de
rapprochement via les dessécher
le deuxième c'est tuer la tva mais sur
président évidemment ces sujets clés la
vraie différence entre la vraie
différence entre nous et les autres pays
à deux différences et notamment
l'allemagne c'est l'impôt
surconsommation et le le problème de nos
taxes de nos cotisations sociales qui
les payent donc comment est ce qu elles
sont réglées donc en réalité quand on
regarde bien ces sujets là que vous
essayez de traiter alors il faut voir
comment le traite mais sérieux et
troisième sujet c'est ça c'est un point
d'accord avec avec délice et la
fiscalité de l'épargné je suis frappé
quand on parle beaucoup de fiscalité de
de patrimoine on s'obstine à évoquer
essentiellement le prince du stock
on traite assez peu le problème des
déchets succession est pas du tout le
propos est très peu le problème des
revenus de lait par mois je considère
comme d'hab il que le sujet clé
j'essayais de le dire de manière
peut-être
maladroite non pas forcément maladroite
mais après 6 c'est que le thème que nous
avons à traiter d'imbécile été là je ne
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec avec
thomas thomas il a de la simplification
et l'équité manger l'investissement
l'épargné l'investissement c'est que
chacun son point d'entrée du système
fiscal est évidemment mon système fiscal
enfin celui le problème que je trouve
prioritaire c'est celui de voir comment
on peut au fonds fiscalisés
les revenus de l'épargné en fonction non
pas d'ailleurs de tellement de ça ce
serait une vraie révolution
tellement dudu de l'instrument utilisé
assure aux ihu et pas de réglementer
mais de l'engagement que les gens
prennent vérifier ex post que
l'engagement pour qu'il prenne sur la
durée de leur épargne qu'ils vont
réaliser et du type d'investissement qui
vont réaliser
c'est ça le prend au jeu dire ça a l'air
un peu c'était vrai sens que c'est très
con c'est très j'ai pas dis que ça
marche et j'ai pas dégager des solutions
j'ai dit je lis juste que le sujet si on
considère que le sujet clé c'est les
revenus de l'épargné
c'est à dire soit une épargne de 2 à 30
ans avec l'idée qu'on essaye de régler
les primes de retraite et de financement
de notre économie
on est obligé d'avoir un prime
spécifique qui n'est pas l'heure celui
de de touba c'est à dire de mettre tous
dans un même un unique paquet qui est le
nouvel impôt mais ce que je constate que
ça marche pas de diriger ce qu'est la
durée des produits d'épargné pour la
fiscale jeu ok en tout cas je dis que
c'est un récital discussion j'ai une
solution mais malheureusement on se
rapproche du déjeuner oui aussi ça
marchait je cours il ya un point
d'accord qui ressort continuellement
c'est qu'on a besoin d'une
simplification majeure dans la
proposition que je vais faire en avril
george est un point commun avec ce que
propose thomas piketty c'est-à-dire de
refaire de la de la base cg la base du
système fiscal et donc notamment d'avoir
un taux de csg
donc j'explique dans le livre comment je
l'obtiens mais qui serait à 15% sur tous
les revenus de toutes natures qui serait
soit capital soit travail et ce taux oui
mais je sais mais tu ne te dira dans le
livre comment gérer parce que notamment
pour ce qui est des revenus du travail
je bascule quatre points de cotisations
maladie et je relève le bambin donc la
cuisiner et en dehors d'ici donc une
fois la réforme fait on a un taux de csg
de deux voilà on a un taux de 15% sur
sur leurs revenus du patrimoine et sur
le revenu du travail est là où j'ai une
différence totale et ça je je je vous le
dis on pourra en reparler ce qui est
absolument décisive je suis alors que je
pense que la base doit être la même
je suis totalement opposé à la fusion
cgi rpp tout simplement parce que
indépendamment du travail en chambre
d'économistes il y à une nécessité
absolue c'est que à la fin du mois le
trésor fait des chèques et à la csg
prélevée à la source étant acceptées et
étant une ressource régulière fusionner
la csg et lire pp pour en faire à
l'arrivée ce qui est dans le rôle dans
la proposition de thomas alins pôle sera
progressif qui pourrait être en partie
rejeté par beaucoup des membres de notre
société pourrait conduire à un choc sur
la ressource fiscale effective du trésor
qui ferait extrêmement dangereux mais
sous ces réserves techniques on est
d'accord sur un point clé c'est que la
base doit être fortement élargis 2 qu'il
faut supprimer les niches et de ce point
de vue là je vais montrer qu'on peut
faire une réforme qui rapporte plus que
la réforme actuelle puisque comme je les
dis nous allons devoir réduire
massivement déficits publics tout en
étant compétitif au plan européen et
tout en évitant le problème qui est
évoqué à juste titre c'est l'abaissement
du taux marginal pour les plus hauts
revenus qui est insupportable
est ce si on l'obtient en supprimant les
niches alors reste une question
importante qui est au coeur de la
réflexion que vous avez sur la réforme
du patrimoine sous réserve qu'on aille
dans cette direction et ça et ça me fait
que confus
armée le diagnostic général qu'on ne
peut faire qu'une réforme d'ensemble
parce que si on veut élargir les bases
et à baisser massivement les taux on
peut pas faire autrement mais sous
réserve donc qu'on aille dans cette
direction
faut-il ou non c'est quand même
maintenant fondamentalement le coeur du
débat entre nous quatre
faut-il accepter ou non des taux une
dualité entre fiscalité du capital et
fiscalité du travail ou est ce qu'il
faut tout mettre sur le même barème
alors c'est une question décisive mais
il est clair que et j'espère que c'est
parfaitement compris entre nous tous on
ne peut pas avoir une réponse
intelligente à la question de la dualité
si on n'a pas fait d'abord la réforme
visant à élargir massivement les bases
et abaisser les taux parce que si on a
fait d'abord cette réforme quels que
soient les les taux qu'on retient si on
a fait cette réforme on se rend compte
qu'on a alors à ce moment là des
fiscalités intrinsèque moyenne sur le
capital et le travail qu'ils deviennent
trop proches en prenant des bases et en
abaissant en abaissant les taux et à ce
moment là le problème de la dualité
devient beaucoup moins fort puisque il
n'ya plus les écarts qu'on a aujourd'hui
deuxième deuxième point qui est qui est
également clé c'est que on ne parle que
de fiscalité on oublie les cotisations
sociales
même si on fait une réforme globale on
ne pourra pas supprimer toutes les
cotisations sociales d'ailleurs dans
dans le bouquin je rappelle que il est
faux de vouloir traiter de la même façon
les cotisations sociales liées à la
protection sociale individuelle et
celles liées à la protection sociale
collective
pour ce qui est la protection sociale
individuelle retraites accidents du
travail
il faut que ça reste cotisation
individuelle sur le salaire puisqu'on
reçoit directement à la hauteur de sa
cotisation et que donc ce qui est arrivé
c'est uniquement ce qui concerne santé
famille c'est un point de divergence
majeure par rapport à thomas met donc
sur ce point là si si on va dans cette
direction il va de toute façon toujours
rester des cotisations importante à
titre individuel notamment concernant le
financement des retraites
pargneaux longue il ya un mécanisme qui
est très simple qui est très puissant et
qui consisterait à dire évidemment sous
une limite d'un certain plafond pour ça
ne devienne pas une niche fiscale
majeure c'est tout simplement de détaxer
à la cotisation sociale
les versements dans les fonds de pension
c'est à dire de traiter de façon neutre
les versements qui sont aujourd'hui des
taxes et socialement et fiscalement dans
la retraite par répartition est de faire
le même traitement pour la retraite en
capitalisation
il n'y aurait pas besoin ensuite si on
fait donc un traitement équivalent au
niveau des cotisations sociales de ce
qui va dans les fonds de pension et de
ce qui est versé au titre des
cotisations pour la répartition on n'a
pas d'eau on aura un mécanisme naturel
qui va envoyer des flux extrêmement
puissant vers des fonds de pension à ce
moment là on sera justifié de dire en
contrepartie de cet avantage il ne faut
pas hésiter à ce moment là à voir une
exigence très forte et en disant si on
crée des fonds de pension il faut que la
moitié soit dans un capital-actions
puisque si on a fait le diagnostic que
la priorité absolue du pays c'est de
reconstruire une base productive
ça ne peut se faire qu'en déplaçant des
flux majeure vers l' épargne en actions
mais comme il n'y aura plus de déficits
publics l'épargné et à s'investir
forcément dans l'économie productive
monsieur président juste une remarque je
vais je rebondis c'est très important
comme vous le savez non seulement il
yal'affaire de deux dépôts de l'epargne
mais derrière ça il ya la possibilité
que les acteurs qui gèrent l'épargné
puissent investir en actions
quand vous savez solvabilité 2 qui
or si on arrive à des cils et si le
si c'est mal oui mais c'est quand même
majeur ça si on arrive à faire que les
gens s'engagent c'est que en réalité
comme vous déposez votre votre argent
mais taux d'assurance vie vous savez
qu'on peut en sortir comme on veut si
vous supprimez cette possibilité là pour
partie sa vis-à-vis de solvabilité 2 ça
autorise la compagnie d'assurance ou le
l'acteur l'investisseur à pouvoir
investir en actions de ses majeurs comme
le commissaire com fr
reconnaissant parce que c'est juste une
question à monsieur piketty qui est
adepte de liesse pense qu'il est une
évaluation actualisée du patrimoine la
familiarisation du barème de l'isf
en fait il est d'une serveuse on les
familiariser puisque on regarde le
patrimoine du couple pour savoir si on
franchit 800000 euros et en particulier
un couple qui se sépare tombe
mécaniquement 1 400 milles alors qu'il
était à 800 milles enfin tout cas si
tout était en communauté ce qui est
quand même assez bizarre quand on y
pense c'est faire s'il était vraiment
familial pour le coup on diviserait par
deux le patrimoine du couple pour savoir
s'il est imposable et c'est même assez
curieux dans le fond d'aucun huit mois
je serais plutôt pour rien dire 1 1-10
visualisation du du barème du barème de
l'ir sf au bout alors franchement une
familiarisation avec un quotient mais
c'est assez curieux d'avoir un seuil qui
est le même pour des personnes seules et
pour les couples griffon s'émeut c'est
même très étrange une entrave à la
nuptialité si c'est juste d' assez
illogique dans le fond ça y'a pas raison
de la bonne gestion patrimoniale que de
se marier
monsieur tu es smara sur ce juste pour
pour rebondir sur d'abord sur le
scepticisme affiché par thomas vis-à-vis
de l'incitation à l'épargné longue
il est vrai que la fiscalité individuel
fonctionne pas nécessairement très bien
ceci dit il ya des tas d'autres
mécanismes pour inciter les gens à
épargner à long terme en particulier
tout ce qui est option par défaut tout
ce qui efface et au niveau de
l'entreprise donc en fait là il faudrait
que l'épargné salariale servent à
l'épargné longue la vérité c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle l'epargne salariale
sert juste de mon mécanisme de d'évasion
fiscale
voilà les fonds d'intéressement ou de
participation
voilà est le deuxième point c'est en ce
qui concerne la progressivité
donc je vous invite à regarder l'exemple
hollandais qui fait une espèce de
mélange entre entre entre l' isf et et
l'impôt sur le revenu en supposant que
vous gagnez 4 % sur votre patrimoine
c'est le revenu notionnels voilà
exactement et mais qui exclut la
résidence principale dans leur cas moi
je suis pour l'inclure mais chacun son
truc
voilà bien messieurs merci d'avoir
répondu aux propos et aux interrogations
du rapporteur général si vous le voulez
bien maintenant je vais inviter mes
collègues qui souhaite vous interroger
au faire part de leurs observations à
s'exprimer successivement et puis vous
répondrais globalement sur saint-etienne
a peut-être des obligations
chronologique bien et bien le saoût nous
souhaitons plein succès à la publication
prochaine de votre livre le chat dédié
être tous vos livres vicieux qui alors
il y avait une question nicole bricq
pour régis un spécial parce que moi je
veux pas anticiper sur les autres mais s
adresser à tous les deux à jean hervé
lorenzi à christian saint-etienne
qu'est-ce que vous avez développé une
finalité de la fiscalité
vous êtes tous d'accord pour qu'il ait
une réforme globale donc mais je poserai
une question henry thomas piketty là
dessus et vous vous développez
finalement une fiscalité qui serait
favorable à l'offre
pour faire simple c'est à dire renforcer
le tissu productif et parle de long
terme et c'est alors la question que je
vais vous poser c'est que on peut
complètement partager cet objectif parce
que vous avez raison sur vos précieux
posée mais quand finalement on pose la
question au gouvernement parce qu'il
faut quand même partir de la réalité et
qu est-ce qu on nous répond on nous
répond ah mais vous avez le crédit impôt
recherche formidable vous avez
l' isf le de la dérivation vers les pme
formidable et vous avez
les assauts sur l'assurance vie qui est
énorme ce qui part en unités de compte
formidable avec une fiscalité
préférentiels donc la question que je
vous pose c'est comment vous êtes vous
êtes capable de définir une fiscalité
propre à encourager cet effort vers
l'économie voilà parce que là vous elle
vous avez dit des choses les deux pas de
deux remarques la première c'est que ce
que ce qui est évoqué cela le la sphère
de les chiffres qui sont évoqués l'un
pour cherche et ça fait peut-être 5 6
milliards d'euros en tout est bon on
peut imaginer que l'effort pour
reconstituer une base d'offres qui se
substitue à ce que nous avons perdu le
sujet de tout et c'est pas particulier
la france c'est vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup plus importants moi je cite le
chiffre de 30 milliards mais je veux
dire il est comme tous les fils
discutable donc on n'est pas du tout
dans les ordres de grandeur de ce qu'il
faut pour pouvoir transférer des parle
d'investissement sous toutes les formes
y compris pour les pme enfin tous
peuvent qu'on peut imaginer
deuxième donc le l'argumentation du
gouvernement et comme toujours c'est la
sienne points elle n'est pas
proportionnée à l'ampleur du sujet qu'il
faut traiter et c'est vraiment la
difficulté majeure que nous avons moi
j'insiste beaucoup sur les années 2012
2013 2014
je me demande ce que sera le taux de
croissance en europe y compris en
allemagne dont on nous donne l'eau
explique ma tâche que soir qui reçoit
formidable je pose la question sur 2012
sur 2012 de deuxième deuxième sujet
deuxième sujet bah ça a été évoqué aussi
par david 1 c c'est l'idée que on a
peut-être un désaccord sur le sur
l'utilisation après dry parle moi je
suis plus je suis plus pour que ça serve
qu'on le conte la canalise mais c'est
céder tous les moyens traditionnels de 2
la fiscalité qu'on peut imaginer
aujourd'hui un débat sur l'assurance vie
on a chaud qui est pas très malin le
débat sert que le budget veut absolument
récupérer de l'argent sur une charge est
objectivement tout ça doit se discuter
mais transparente mais je si j'étais à
la place du midi bilité je vous ne
ferait pas ça parce que je trouve que
c'est on a quand même une capacité de
gêner de canaliser de l'epargne dont on
voit en gros l'assurance vie ça fait en
termes obligataire corporate et actions
pas loin de 50 pensant donc c'est c'est
très imprudent dans une situation
conjoncturelle tu es quand même très
délicate
enfin j'ai quand même penser à la
réalité les socio économique en europe
et en france pour les trois quatre ans
qui viennent ce je ne sais pas où ils
vont chercher leurs couleurs prévisions
mais mais mais il faut être très prudent
par rapport à l'argent qu'on peut
canaliser vers l'investissement des
petites grandes entreprises je serai
très prudent j'insiste sur le fait que
2012 me paraît une année qui pourrait
conduire à ce que la conjoncture en
europe soit avec un taux de croissance
inférieur à 1%
bonjour les bons joueurs et le marché y
travaillent sur ce plan-là je serais
très très prudent sur ce thème là ce qui
vient d'être dit dans les mécanismes
vous avez rappelé le mécanisme principal
c'est le crédit d'impôt recherche qui
est autour de 4 milliards et les autres
ensemble ça fait un package de 5
mais si on regarde ce package
l'essentiel va en réalité aux grandes
entreprises internationalisées qui
n'investissent plus en france dont on a
besoin
dont on a impérativement besoin pour
structurer des filières mais qui
m'aimait qui n'investissent eu en france
on a tous en tête les stratégies
différentes des constructeurs
automobiles allemands et français les
allemands font tout pour rester en
france en allemagne et les français
faisant tout pour quitter la france en
tous cas surtout pour renault même si
c'est moins le cas pour peugeot
alors sur sur la question que vous posez
effectivement si on devait retenir non
de grandeur
et surtout destination quelle est la
nature du secteur productif
juste une remarque préliminaire malgré
tout les malheurs qui sont les nôtres
mais nous avons aussi beaucoup de motifs
de satisfaction puisque nous continuons
malgré tout de vivre dans le plus beau
pays du monde donc c'est un élément clé
de compétitivité au plan mondial mais
ayant rappelé ce point si on regarde les
25 années se terminant en 2007 avant la
crise et ça c'est ça c'est un chiffre
que vous devriez avoir en tête matin
midi et soir
les 25 si on regarde les 25 années se
terminant en 2007
l'économie française a créé deux
millions et demi d'emplois malgré malgré
toutes les difficultés l'économie
française a créé deux millions et demi
d'emplois sur les 25 années se terminant
en 2007 les grands les entreprises de
plus de 250 personnes ont supprimé un
demi million d'emplois les entreprises
de plus de 250 personnes sont les
principales bénéficiaires du crédit
d'impôt recherche et d autres mécanismes
vous avez rappelé ce qui veut dire quoi
mais ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut
dire que les entreprises qui ont créé de
l'emploi ce sont les entreprises de
moins de 150 personnes donc donc créer
trois millions d'emplois
or quelle et si on regarde et si on re
boucle avec ce que disait jean hervé
lorenzi sur la nécessité de reconstruire
notre système productif de quoi on parle
7 en réalité on parle de créer en
urgence trois millions d'emplois
productifs en france c'est ça la nature
de l'ampleur pour un pays qu'elle 63
millions de résidents sur le territoire
métropolitain
si on veut avoir des taux d'emploi
comparable aux autres pays ce qui
permettrait d'abaisser effectivement le
poids de la dépense publique qui si une
part est très important de la dépense
publique va vers les 3 millions de gens
qui ne travaille pas on qu'on maintient
la tête hors de l'eau avec de la
protection sociale alors que s'ils
travaillaient ça coûterait beaucoup
moins cher et qui puisent elles
cotiseraient donc le problème
fondamental c'est comment on créer 3
millions d'emplois productifs
ça ne viendra pas des grandes
entreprises ça viendra pour faire court
des boîtes de 50 qui passe à 200 voilà
donc tous là toute la réflexion fiscale
du parlement et de l'est et du
gouvernement aujourd'hui et après 2012
c'est comment on construit un système
fiscal qui contribue à ce que les boîtes
de 50 est envie de passer à 300 ou how à
400 et c'est elle qui vont créer
l'emploi
donc si c'est elle qui vont créer les 3
millions d'emplois dont on a besoin de
quoi ont-elles besoin elles ont besoin
pour réussir ce tour de force de créer 3
millions d'emplois un horizon qui fasse
sens du point de vue les problèmes de
compétitivité que nous avons kick de 7
ou 8 ans donc c'est un 400000 emplois
dans ce secteur c'est c'est quelque
chose qui exige 20 milliards
effectivement minimum de fonds propres
alloués à ces pme qui leur permettrait
de lever par ailleurs de l'endettement
qui leur rapporterait 30 à 40 milliards
d'euros de capitaux long pour développer
l'activité
donc si si je conclus sur ces 20
milliards d'euros
ils ne peuvent venir effectivement que
d'un mécanisme de très long terme qu'on
l'appelle fonds de pension assurances
vie allongée ça ne peut venir que d'un
mécanisme de très long terme qui
favorise la dérivation de l'épargné vers
l'investissement productif mais
également et ça c'est ses clefs et
j'observe d'ailleurs que c'était une
proposition à un moment donné de la
plate forme parti socialiste qui était
d'avoir un taudis s à réduire de moitié
sur les bénéfices mis en réserve et je
pense que c'est que c'est de ces deux
mesures pour n'obtiendra les 20000 ya 30
milliards d'euros de capitaux productifs
par an dont on a besoin pour avoir en
sept à huit ans et trois millions
d'emplois productifs qui nous manque
on vous libère merci infiniment d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation alors
maintenant j'appelle nos collègues et à
s'exprimer successivement joël bourdin à
messieurs si vous avez encore quelques
instants bon oui monsieur le président
j'ai simplement eu une observation est
une question d'observation c'est une
question mais c'était sur l'épargné et
la structure des des stocks de produits
de produits d'epargne c'est vrai qu'on
observe de choses c'est que le taux
dépargne en france est élevé il faut se
réjouir mais que en revanche quand on
regarde la structure des désaffectations
on trouve que le portefeuille non
risqués est autant rémunérés que
portefeuille l'espèce est une anomalie
dans les modèles économiques et
financiers et de comment faire pour
modifier cela ça serait ma question
technique de deuxième chose c'est une
question de de conceptualisation parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de patrimoine mais
je ne suis pas sûr
chers collègues économistes qu'on ait
une bonne définition du patrimoine et
que des investigations devraient un peu
plus poussées sur le contenu du
patrimoine des objets d'art ça fait
partie du patrimoine dans la réalité je
ne pense même pas à la famille ville et
string mais même en ayant en étant
beaucoup plus modeste mais même en étant
beaucoup plus modeste il y a il y a
quand même toute une partie de les
patrimoines qui sont investis dans des
objets d'art et apparemment et
apparemment ce patrimoine serait plutôt
en train de se gonfler quand on regarde
sur internet le cours des objets d'art
ici ou ailleurs
un en art moderne on a beaucoup plus de
la sic en arts premiers et cetera
on se dit qu'il ya une espèce de
triangle des bermudes de de l'epagne et
non bien rien l'exonération document
l'exonération totale et absolument donc
ma question est celle-ci est-ce qu'on a
une évaluation est ce que les travaux
sont menés sur l'évaluation de ces
partis des pâtés man que ce soit en
france
l'extérieur mais il me semble que c'est
une nécessité alors qu'on parle de
prospective sur la fiscalité il faudrait
qu'on ait des concepts les packs merci
bourdin françois fortassin monsieur le
président merci
moi je veux dire qu' à l'instant
actuelle je suis entre deux positions
tout à fait contradictoires d'un côté
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
j'ai apprécié ce qui a été dit notamment
au travers de certains divergences sur
un plan intellectuel était très
intéressant mais en même temps je suis
très en colère
je suis très en colère parce que en
fonction de ce qu'il n'a pas été dit au
fomc encore faire une réforme la
fiscalité
il faut partir de quelques règles
comment fait-on pour lutter contre
quelque chose qui est le fléau des 30
dernières années à savoir que l'éventail
des revenus du pays au lieu de se
réduire cet écart t220 en est on pense
que la progressivité significative de
l'impôt est une bonne chose ou pas
troisièmement on a parlé de fiscalité
des entreprises
ben je regrette mais il ya encore cinq
ans l'irlande à paris c'est comme une
sorte d'eldorado pour les entreprises
parce que on ne payait pas une fiscalité
très forte
on a vu ce que ça me met en irlande ne
jeûne rappelle quand même qu'il ya cinq
ans beaucoup de jeunes look pays partait
tous en irlande
parce que c'est là où il fallait aller
si on voulait avoir un événement
significatif est en fait pour ma part je
peux dire que il y a deux grandes
catégories de contribuables
il faudrait quand même en parler plus
être fière ceux qui peuvent payer les
impôts et je ne souhaite pas payer
il ya ceux qui peuvent pas et qui
voudraient impayés alors ça je crois
qu'il faut pas tenir compte et l'épargné
retraite c'est très bien mais quelle
signification sera pour un type qui
gagne 100 euros par mois
merci d'envoyer des questions techniques
mais si c'était pas la peine d'y arriver
j'ai juste j'ai juste une une
interrogation tout de même je voulais
tout d'abord avant de poser cette
question me féliciter de l'effort jour
des économistes pour rendre la fiscalité
j'allais dire populaire au sens premier
du terme
accessible et monsieur desmare a parlé
de la société translucide supplier ti
évoque à travers son ouvrage et et
l'effort entrepris dans la démocratie
participative justement cette
association de l'opinion à la réflexion
à mener et puis les différences ouvrages
qui sont sortis aujourd'hui ils sont
tous accessibles à tous donc je crois
que c'est important compte tenu de
l'étendue du problème
il nous est posée la question porte sur
le grand méchant loup de la
délocalisation
parce que quand le petit chaperon rouge
s'engage sur le sentier de la réforme
fiscale et et s'apprête à accueillir tel
ou tel champignons fiscale en lui dis
attention petit chaperon rouge si tu va
cueillir tel champignons fiscal est bien
le grand méchant loup va peut-être
surgir le grand méchant loup de la
délocalisation
parce que tu vas faire peur et donc il y
aura un risque de délocalisation
d'acteurs d'entreprise c'est monsieur
saint-etienne
j'aurais mais interrogé sur le sujet
évoqué tout à l'heure les 800 millions
d'uc et fisc en dix ans lola si on
supprime ça c'est ici le bouquet
fiscales donc supprimé attention
délocalisation effets pervers redoutable
etc etc
et j'ai trouvé dans l'est les échos
également les mêmes attaques contre le
ce qui est qualifié de l'inquiétant de
révolution fiscale de thomas piketty
c'est dans les échos ce lundi où on
attaque et aussi à zéro le là attention
on va créer une évasion extraordinaire
donc il ya des économies sans face de
nous est ce que au fond ce grand méchant
loup de la décolonisation quelqu'un
capable d'écrire parce que moi j'essaie
de lire partout et de comprendre de quoi
il s'agit
jamais réussi à comprendre je regarde
les chiffres il ya des allées iliad est
venue des retours et on sait pas très
bien mesuré alors si vous avez un
éclairage ponctuelles ça peut être
intéressant
serge dassault dans lé tard je passerais
non on va faire deux remarques
je n'apporte pas de discussion je pense
imposions patrimoine tel impôt imbécile
11.6 économique un impôt qui tue
l'économie un impôt qui tue ceux qui
réussissent et qui s'en vante
rien ne peut qu'ils tuent l'économie du
pays il ya plus de recettes
il ya plus personne pour travailler
alors c'est très joli d'hier a fait
payer les riches
mais là ils savent on est happé driss il
ya plus personne et ceux qui
investissent aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont
pas là pour investir ils sont partis
ailleurs à l'emploi toujours parler de
croissance
et si on avait gardé tous les
responsables écouter économies qui sont
partis on a plusieurs milliards beaucoup
les gars qui sont partis et qui servait
plus utile en france et en belgique en
angleterre et en suisse
deuxième point c'est que je suis
d'accord avec monsieur saint-etienne
quand ils décommandent de politique
industrielle
c'est vrai on a loupé en france en
nombre de la nouvelle industrie google
internet et même les voitures
électriques n'a rien fait pour ça on n'a
pas de pratiquer un ciel alors nazis
étaient si les entreprises qui
réussissent parce qu'elles sont bonnes
je ne citerai pas ceux qui réussissent
sur le connais quelques jeunes mais
c'est pas grâce au gouvernement c'est
parce qu'ils sont bons et qu'ils ont
fondé le technicien mais s'il y avait
une politique c'est un essai à chromé en
chine
en chine on va faire ceci ou inversement
vers ceux ci envers cela donne l'argent
pour ça il est des gens et forme les
jeunes pensent à nous on sent même pas
les jeunes pour ça donc au monde des
jeux et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont ils
sont malheureusement un peu trop au
chômage parce qu'on les forme pas et
puis ils n'ont pas de métier alors bon
évidemment très fade et on crée pas nier
que des dents pas pour ça voilà ça ne
nécessite aucune discussion c'est de mon
avis
mieux vaut merci de ta de nous avoir
pendant une heure une heure la nuit
vraiment à part très utile merci merci
je cherche à sous marie-hélène des
esgaulx
merci monsieur président moi je vous ai
trouvé un peu sévère les uns et les
autres sur lacombe parisot avait la
volonté de comparaison entre la france
et l'allemagne parce que je crois qu'on
a absolument besoin de convergence en
europe et pour répondre donc à des
problèmes de mondialisation de
globalisation et pour aller vers cette
convergence il faut d'abord faire une
comparaison sincère et complète sur l'
isf je regrettais aussi que vous ne
disiez pas que parce qu'on vous ait fait
la comparaison mais la taxe foncière
vous avez trouvé beaucoup de vertus l
isf ou sur le plan de l'équité pendant
de vous rappeler quand même que moi je
trouve que c'est absolument anormal
qu'on soit imposée sur des valeurs
virtuelles
alors quoi le monde qu'en mettant la
barre où vous l'avez proposée à 3
milliards à 3 millions barre des 2 euros
les choses se règlent
mais franchement aujourd'hui on revienne
pas là-dessus demande reconnaît le
problème c'est absolument ahurissant
d'être être imposée sur un bien qu'on a
acheté 100 qui aujourd'hui soit disant
vos cinq sens mais on verra jamais les
cinq sens puisqu'on n'a pas du tout
l'intention de le vendre
bon alors là aujourd'hui quand même
quand vous étiez passé à côté de ce web
des valeurs virtuelles parfois par
contre j'ai parfaitement compris et bien
aimé la préconisation de jean hervé
lorenzi d'allonger l'epargne pour
qu'elle puisse être disponible pour des
investissements de long terme ça je
pense que l'idée qui est très
intéressant d à laquelle on peut
parfaitement rajouter donc le problème
de l'épargne-retraite soulever par david
thesse part sauf que une fois qu'on a
dit ça
comment on le fait est là je crains un
mois que on est très peu de marge de
manoeuvre et qu'en fait les chiffres
soient pas du tout à la hauteur des
enjeux et des besoins parce que joël
bourdin a dit ce que je voulais dire
savoir que il a rappelle très justement
que le taux d'épargné français est
extrêmement élevé il est parmi les plus
élevés donc c'est pas par rapport à ça
qu'on va trouver des marges de manoeuvre
et quand on regarde la composition du
patrimoine des français moi je voudrais
rappeler que 80% de ce patrimoine c'est
des biens immobiliers
et quand on regarde aussi l'historique
de ses biens immobiliers
10 ans ça a doublé mais sa doubler à
cause du prix de l'immobilier
je vois pas là non plus tellement de
marge de manoeuvre
voilà ce que je voulais simplement
allongé je trouve que l'idée le
diagnostic est certainement bon et
règles plein de problèmes que vous avez
soulevé des eaux les autres mais je vois
pas très bien les moyens d'y arriver en
termes de chiffres macro économie on est
maintenant à jean paul alduy
oui question très bref je vous ai
entendu j'ai pas lu votre livre
simplement lu l'article des échos qui
vous critiquent hier il ya quelque chose
qui m'inquiète
ou plutôt qui me m'oblige à vous
demander d'écrire un autre livre
quand vous mettez la taxe d'habitation
en effet qui est un un pont dans le
volume et est tout à fait important je
vous signale que c'est un impôt qui est
la base de l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités locales qui est la base de
l'autonomie fiscale du bloc communal et
même des départements
je veux dire par là que si vous voulez
aller au bout de votre réforme fiscale
il faut engager une autre réforme qui
est celle de la suppression de
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
locales pour arriver à l'autonomie
financière comme en allemagne
les allemands n'y a pas d'autonomie
fiscale ou très faible 10 ou 15%
par contre personne ne peut nier que
l'allemagne est un pays décentralisé
pourrait même penser qu'il est plutôt
plus décentralisée que le nôtre donc il
me semble que vous êtes obligés d'écrire
un second vivre qui est celui de de cet
autre révolution qui est de supprimer
l'autonomie fiscale pour en faire une
économie financière et est donc à partir
la modifier profondément la fiscalité
locale
je suis là en plus de ceux qui pensent
que c'est la seule façon de réformer la
taxe d'habitation et la taxe foncière on
n'y arrivera jamais on y arrive à quand
la supprimant est en passe
par un mécanisme à l'allemande de
redistribution par le haut niveau
national or vous avez tout de suite
compris que je suis ultra minoritaire
sur ce sujet et qu'en plus j'ai un peu
de courage puisque je suis un sénateur
renouvelables donc pour dire ça dans les
communes
c'est assez difficile et bien hélas
hélas parce qu'on peut refonder le pacte
républicain sur les prélèvements
obligatoires
madame brigue pour une ultime question
coûté d'accord il est très tard c'était
par rapport à thomas piketty parce que
françois à lui comme moi du reste les
échos mais moi j'ai lu libération d'hier
et vous avez j'ai voulu aussi les écoute
mais vous avez posé quatre questions à
moi même et à mes amis d'aller au bout
d'une démarche un peu révolutionnaire
qui est celle que vous avez dans votre
livre
moi je pense que votre est formel est
très séduisante et comme le chaperon
rouge était quand même du genre féminin
moi elle me séduit dans la mesure où
elle est là elle favorise beaucoup les
femmes et notamment au travers de de la
réforme marraine etc je reviens pas un
problème technique mais d'un sujet qui
devrait effectivement être posée à tout
à tous les acteurs politiques c'est
celui de l'individualisation et bien moi
je suis je le dis je suis favorable
depuis des années à l'individualisation
alors qu'ils touchent pas uniquement un
problème technique fiscales qui touchent
une vision de la société doux doux de
coûts la difficulté et je voudrais dire
que ce débat
ce ne sera pas une question ce débat a
déjà été posée au sein de ma formation
politique il ya plus d'une dizaine
d'années et qu'il a été très vite
refermée et je pense que si on veut
vraiment faire une vraie révolution
fiscale
il faut
il faut le faire mais on touche
énormément d'intérêt ce qui fait que à
partir d'une idée juste et qui
correspond à la société telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui en plus eh bien on peut
tout faire capoter
c'est ça la difficulté quand on prône
quelque chose qui touche bien au delà du
de la fiscalité mais je sais que j'ai vu
aussi que philippe marini avait aussi
dit que c'était un sujet intéressant
c'est un excellent sujet de clivage
voilà un vrai débat belle structure et
moi j'aime bien les débats structuré et
je pense que là dessus on aurait on
devrait avoir un très bel jaoui tout à
fait ça je suis dit c'est prenant c'est
vraiment pro ne s'est pas pour ce matin
oui
il fallait le dire bien messieurs sans
relancer le débat
les observations d'interrogations qui
ont été exprimés appel tel de votre part
des remarques des réponses chez piketty
balayé très rapidement les différentes
questions le l'individualisation énorme
question oui ça bouleverse beaucoup de
repères c'est en même temps une
je pense que beaucoup de personnes
peuvent comprendre que c'est la seule
façon finalement de sortir la question
des différentes formes de vie familiale
du conflit politique on va pas
recommencer chaque automne à discuter
des mérites respectifs des des pacsés
par rapport aux divorcés et des pacsés
par rapport à des règles sur des demi
part qu'on modifie tout le temps et des
triple déclaration si on veut sortir
cette question du débat politique
l'individuation à la seule façon je note
au passage que non seulement l'espagne
l'italie tous les pays nordiques le
royaume uni l'ont fait avec des bords
politiques très différents si on regarde
qui a fait cette réforme dans ces
différents pays que l'allemagne va le
faire un jour ou l'autre c'est déjà
discuté on se rend bien compte
l'allemagne a besoin notamment avec ces
femmes actives d'être quand même un peu
plus à chaque oeil en disant un et de ce
point de vue là l'individualisation sera
sur l'agenda politique allemand dans les
années qui viennent c'est certain donc
bon on peut attendre d'être le seul pays
pour le faire c'est une possibilité mais
enfin je crois qu'il faut le faut quand
même on est obligé de prendre la
question au sérieux le les autres
aspects sur les questions je voudrais
dire que le bon on n'a pas effectivement
suffisamment insisté sur le fait qu on
est dans un contexte économique qui se
caractérise effectivement par un très
fort accroissement des inégalités des
patrimoines qui ne se sont jamais aussi
bien portés des revenus de patronne qui
sont jamais aussi bien portés alors on
peut pas tout faire au niveau français
il ya des choses qui ne peuvent être
fait qu'au niveau européen il est
évident que sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
c'est au niveau européen que les choses
vont se passer
apparemment vont commencer quand même à
bouger c'est à dire que je crois que les
uns et les autres se rendent compte que
c'est quand même très difficile d'aller
au secours des banques irlandaises et de
l'irlande sans au minimum exigé un
relèvement du taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés qui à peine des limites à la
bêtise quelques bars et on peut pas
comme ça une grande partie quand même de
la crise financière irlandaise est due à
l'opacité comptable de ces sociétés qui
est elle même due à des ce transfert
pricing avec les filiales du continent
européen
totalement délirant
y'a des stratégies d'optimisation
fiscale qui a contribué à l'opacité et
comptables de cette société on peut pas
donc ces choses vont bouger et c'est là
quand christian saint-etienne je suis
l'aîné plus l'armée disais tout à
l'heure l'avenir de l'europe c'est la
baisse indéfinie de l'impôt sur les
sociétés et l'augmentation est défini de
l'impôt sur la consommation
je pense que non je pense que non
seulement ce n'est pas l'avenir d'un
point de vue économique rationnel mais
c'est pas non plus politiquement
l'avenir on se rend compte qu'il ya des
réactions sur l'impôt société qui
peuvent se produire maintenant le fait
que certaines choses ne puisse être
traitée qu'au niveau européen n'implique
pas qu'on peut rien faire au niveau
français et nous on a la conviction et
on l'expliquent dans le bouquin que ce
qu'on défend et parfaitement raisonnable
au niveau français et que cette réforme
fiscale qu'on propose peut-être fait ici
et maintenant sans demander la
permission de personnes maintenant ceux
qui ne sont pas convaincus par notre
barème d'imposition donc la personne des
échos trouvé que à 100000 euros par mois
donc à sens unique valait que la
personne soit taxée à moins de 60% bon
peut-être 50 % 40 % pour que chacun
donne son chiffre on parle quand même de
revenu à 100 smic mensuel la kobama de
l'oph bon mais on peut dire qu'il faut
il faut que le taux d'imposition soit
seulement 2 40% pour que la personne il
lui reste 60 fixe mensuel de revenus
disponibles chaque mois bon c'est géré
chacun défend que chacun défende son
barème simplement tous payent un stère
si vous voulez réduire les taureaux vous
allez voir augmenter les taux sur les
classes moyennes
l'avantagé quand même énorme du barème
qu'on propose comme goethe à l'heure
c'est qui permet de réduire les impôts
sur les classes moyennes jusqu'à des
niveaux de revenus très élevés 6 7000
euros par mois ça va quand même des
avantages
maintenant que chacun que chacun propose
son barème que tout se fasse dans la
transparence
pas de difficultés juste pour un dernier
point beau serge dassault n'est plus la
halle l'impôt sur le patrimoine
est contraire à la rationalité humaine
doit être supprimée bon c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça quand même jeu
juste rappeler que maurice tallec était
pas exactement un homme de gauche
défendent l impôt sur le patrimoine
comme l'impôt rationnelle par excellence
au nom d'une vision incitatives telles
idées c'était juste pour pousser les
gens à avoir un rendement élevé sur le
patrimoine
maintenant c'est une logique qui a ses
limites parce qu'il ya aussi un côté
assurantielle de la fiscalité c'est lé
rendement du patrimoine peuvent peuvent
être très volatiles niveau d'une société
mais aussi au niveau individuel donc des
gens peuvent se retrouver avec des très
haut rendement ou des rendements
violemment négatif non pas parce qu'ils
ont mis beaucoup d'efforts ils ont été
très dynamiques mais juste parce qu'ils
ont eu beaucoup de chance ou très peu de
chance aussi on base tout sur la
fiscalité sur le patrimoine
ça va pas aller donc faut trouver un
équilibre entre entre cette logique
allait cette logique de fiscalité sur
les revenus
dans le contexte actuel et je conclus
par la houle et patrimoine ne se sont
jamais aussi bien portés il faut revenir
un siècle en arrière pour retrouver des
niveaux de de capitalisation boursière
et immobilière par rapport au revenu
comparable à ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
ce qui est le signe que les détenteurs
de patrimoine se porte bien servi et
l'on peut pas faire comme si les cours
immobiliers les prêts d'immobilier nous
tombait du ciel comme ça les prix de
l'immobilier sont soutenus par un marché
et c'est pas parce que l'émir du koweït
est en train de racheter paris les
étrangers c'est monté de 4 % et 8 % des
achats à paris c'est important mais il
en reste 92 % qui sont faits par des
nationaux des résidents et donc si les
prix sont à ce niveau là c'est tout
simplement qu'il ya des gens qui ont les
moyens pour les soutenir ses prix donc
on revient au point de départ qui est
que les patrimoines se porte bien
il s'agit pas pour autant de les
matraquer mais dans un contexte où les
patrimoines se porte aussi bien et où
les revenus stagnent et en particulier
les salaires stagnent depuis 30 ans
augmente à graignes très faibles
allaient diminuer les impôts sur le
patrimoine
ce qui forcément d'une façon du yacht
sera payé par le travail puisque toute
la richesse vient du travail et du
capital et tous les impôts d'une façon
ou d'une autre tombe sur le travail et
le capital on peut appeler ça tva
sociale inventé tous les noms qu'on veut
d'une façon ou d'une autre pour aller
faire ses courses faut quand même avoir
un revenu du travail ou du capital et
l'impôt va baisser ce pouvoir d'achat
donc donc le
bon je vais pas finir sur une note trop
polémique je vois philippe marini qui tu
veux répondre sur ce drame et mais
posais une question si vous vous
permettez de vous interrompre une
seconde quand on taxe un très hauts
revenus est ce qu'on taxe du travail ou
du cap les deux femmes vous alors vous
vous verrez vos jouets passerieux au
delà de quinze mille euros est-ce qu'on
rémunère le travail ou bien votre
notoriété mais le monde le monde est
multidimensionnelle c'est qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont des très forts revenus
du travail et très peu de capital
accumulé au reçu par héritage et puis
des personnes inversement compte très
peu de revenus du travail etc ont
beaucoup de patrimoines médias les deux
on est dans un monde à deux dimensions
et c'est bien pour ça que supprimer et
vos dividendes ou la mise en réserve de
demain mais il n'ya rien les gens qui
arbitre à la frontière il faut les
prendre en compte dans la misère la
qualité skiable il ya plein de gens qui
n'ont pas la possibilité du fait
simplement qu'ils soient ont pas
beaucoup de patrimoine ont beaucoup aux
revenus du travail élevé puis dégâts les
personnes qui ont par exemple beaucoup
perry t'es con un patrimoine important
ou qu'on fait des plus values
intéressant mais qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de revenus parce qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'activités tout simplement
vous avez les deux et si vous vous
connectez sur révolution fiscale préfère
vous verrez que les deux dimensions
existent ne sont qu'imparfaitement
corrélés dieu merci la correction entre
le revenu et le patrimoine et quand même
être lors de 0,5 ce qui est élevé mais
bon soit la ceni 0 niasse est entre les
deux et la conclusion politique très
simple de tout ça c'est que quand vous
remplacer un milliard ou 2 ou 3 ou 4 de
recettes d'impôt sur la fortune par la
somme équivalente sur l'impôt sur le
revenu vous ne toucherait pas les mêmes
personnes
il n'y a rien à faire ce ne seront pas
du tout les mêmes personnes et
globalement ça va pas dans la bonne
direction pour ce qui est de stimuler
l'activité économique
un tel type de transfert ça je vous mets
au défi de montrer le contraire
je prie juste que
vous avez quand même posé une question
qui est majeure inquiet quand vous dites
la sphère du des délocalisations
fiscales
les chiffres en gros on les a quand même
alors question saint-etienne sont des
signes sont à mon avis un peu excessif
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya du avoir entre
5000 et 10000 personnes à tulle les
chiffres exacts on doit les avoir mais
en tout cas ils sont pas transparents
notre 5000 et 10000 personnes ou ménages
fiscaux qui conquit sont délocalisés et
c'est vrai que ça fait sûrement
plusieurs centaines de milliards de
tonnes donc ce n'est pas négligeable
c'est une absurdité de le considérer
comme comme discuté par rapport à ça que
ton lycées ans n'a pas dit grand chose
je considère deux éléments c'est que on
ne peut pas imaginer tout l'addition
monte revient quelle que soit la volonté
de traiter du sujet de sfk arrêter cela
tu as tout le monde sait la réforme
fiscale en france qui aura lieu cette
année à la fois que l'on aura lieu
l'année prochaine et est donc vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer réforme fiscale
qu'elle soit celle de thomas ou celle de
a molli enfin tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer
si ce problème si le problème de la
taxation du mérou d'une autre impossible
aujourd'hui de la taxation des
défiscaliser d2 localiser pardon n'a pas
lieu
et c'est une des raisons par exemple
pour laquelle je suis plus favorable à
la taxe foncière que l isf puisque la
taxe foncière la plupart de délocaliser
il continue à voir évidemment des
propriétés foncières en france ils
vivent en france
en réalité est donc très largement très
largement ce jeu où je peux voir ça de
près donc la réalité c'est que la taxe
foncière quelque part c'est en tout cas
c'est un élément des discussions que
l'on peut on peut avoir permet d'une
part pour partie de régler le problème
de fiscalité deux des expatriés
mais moi je pense que ça c'est
insuffisant c'est un sujet quand on en
discute avec les allemands qui ont le
même problème parce que dans notre
groupe de travail on a écouté ils ont le
même problème
les gens veulent pas payer d'impôts déjà
argent ils veulent publier d'impôts il
faut qu'on arrive à trouver une manière
de faire à l'américaine un dispositif
qui permet aurait été de rattraper pour
partie le fait que ces allemands
défiscaliser où ces français disent
lisez dans les faits vive dans le pays
d'origine
dans les faits j'utilise les hôpitaux le
truc cities tous toqués c'est quand même
un problème de et vous ne pouvez pas on
peut pas faire de réformes fiscales sous
cette contrainte terrifiant de dès qu'on
dit un mot on ira à lyon tout l'argent
va partir ce qui était pour partie vrai
ce qui est donc il vaut mieux réfléchir
sur le sujet et et sans avoir le minimum
d'équité fiscale
thomas a beaucoup parlé des fils y aider
des fiscs et d'équité en france mais il
ya quand même un sujet majeur c'est que
en gros beaucoup de gros revenus et gros
patrimoines en réalité ne payent pas
d'impôts de la peau est donc ici c'est
un sujet qu'on ne peut pas éliminer de
la discussion
ça c'est mon sentiment et je peux dire
que c'est un élément que chacun vend son
bouquin le 5 avril
je sors un livre qui s'appelle attendait
un très joli titre
un très joli titre qui s'appelle le
fabuleux destin d'une puissance
intermédiaire évidemment de la france de
segi 13 présenter déclinistes et qui
revient notamment sur suse de réforme
fiscale mais sur un sujet - comme on est
moins révolutionnaire car c'est
peut-être là mais moins aussi moins
talentueux peut-être sur cet aspect là
mais qui est notamment règle enfin
essayer de régler ce problème de des
exilés fiscaux qui est quand même un
problème insensé d'un pays peut pas dire
un mot sans qu'on vous dise
ils vont partir oui on nous attendait
vous les avez minimisant monsieur tu es
smara avez vous un livre qui sort début
avril
non j'ai pas de livre et je vais
permettre à tout le monde d'aller
déjeuner rapidement
sur ces bonnes bien nous attendons le
printemps du livre économique
début avril messieurs merci infiniment
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
cette audition était tout à fait
intéressante et vous avez enrichit nos
propres réflexions mais il faudra qu'on
se revoie peut-être sur les impôts de
production et la mondialisation c'est la
fin de cette table ronde merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi si vous souhaitez la
revois elle est disponible en vod sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr bonne
journée à tous sur notre antenne